OF THE SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. BUT I I
GOTTA TELL YOU ARE MAKING A
STATEMENT LIKE THAT HAVING A
BUNCH OF MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM DO WHAT I SAY IS PRETTY
AMAZING.
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
WELCOME USED TO THE JOIN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
CALIFORNIA MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING OUR
CHAIRWOMAN OF JACKSON HER STAFF
FROM THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT. FOR HELPING US
ORGANIZE THIS HEARING. IN FOR
THE WORK THAT YOUR COMMITTEE IS
DONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
DEVASTATING FIRES.
THAT CALIFORNIA FACE THIS PAST
YEAR.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRE SEASON
WAS ABSOLUTELY UNPRECEDENTED.
THE STATE WITNESS NEARLY NINE
THOUSAND WILD FIRES WHICH BURNED
AT ONE POINT TWO MILLION ACRES
DESTROYED NEARLY ELEVEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES IN RESULTED IN THE
UNFORTUNATE DEATH OF AT LEAST.
FORTY SIX INDIVIDUALS.
ADDITIONALLY A TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE
FIVE OF THIS MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FIRES IN RECORDED HISTORY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WILDFIRES ARE
LIKELY TO CONTINUE.
AS WILDFIRES INVOLVED SOME US BE
OUR WAY OF RESPONDING.
WHILE CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM IS WORLD RENOWNED.
IT APPEARS THAT IT'S QUITE
STRAINED AND THAT'S IMPROVEMENTS
DO NEED TO BE MADE.
BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PERSONALLY THANK OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS RECOVERY WORKERS
VOLUNTEERS IN EVERY SINGLE
PERSON ACROSS CALIFORNIA BEYOND.
WHO CAME TO OUR HELP WHEN WE
WERE MOST IN NEED?
DURING OUR DARKEST HOUR THE
SPIRIT OF CALIFORNIA. NEVER
FALTERED.
IN FACT IT ONLY GREW STRONGER.
IT IS WITH THAT SPIRIT THAT WE
MUST RECOVER REBUILD.
AND PREPARE.
THANK YOU ADVANCE TO ALL THE
PANELISTS.
ALSO WAS YOU COULD I CAN SEE WE
HAVE A FULL AGENDA.
SO I URGE EACH OF YOU TO.
KEEP YOUR.
TESTIMONY AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE.
CHAIRWOMAN JACKSON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS AT THIS POINT ON THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DO
NOTE OFF THE SO. WONDERFUL MEN
IN UNIFORM.
WE DON'T SEE ANY WONDERFUL WOMEN
IN UNIFORM PERHAPS
OUR NEXT GO ROUND WILL BE. WELL
REPRESENTED BY THE OTHER FIFTY
TWO PERCENT OF THE POPULATION
WHO I KNOW IN MANY INSTANCES.
WERE VERY ACTIVELY INVOLVED. IN
THE FIGHTING OF THESE FIRES AND
APPRECIATE. THE GREAT WORK THAT
ALL OF YOU HAVE DONE. I KNOW
CHIEF LORENZEN SMILING BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME HE'S
HEARD ME.
OBSERVE WE NEED MORE WOMEN.
TO BE PART OF THIS ILLUSTRIOUS
GROUP. OF.
EXTRAORDINARY PEOPLE AND I DO
THANK YOU ALL FOR FOR THAT
EFFORT AND TALKED ONE ALSO THANK
YOU SENATOR DODD.
I RECALL BACK IN OCTOBER. OVER
FOR EARLY NOVEMBER WHEN I CAME
UP TO VIEW THE WILDFIRES.
CARNAGE THAT HAD BEEN CREATED UP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS. MIND BLOWING IS I THINK
THE ONLY WAY TO DESCRIBE THAT
THE DEVASTATION.
I HADN'T NOT TO.
REALIZE AT THE TIME THAT I WOULD
TO BE EXPERIENCING A VERY
SIMILAR. TRAGEDY IN MY OWN
DISTRICT WHICH IS A REFLECTION
FRANKLY THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
NOW A. TWELVE MONTH THE YEAR
FIRE SEASON.
THAT THE FIRES ARE MORE INTENSE
MORE EXPANSIVE MORE DESTRUCTIVE.
AND MORE PREVALENT THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE SO I THANK YOU FOR.
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER TO.
DISCUSS OUR MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
IN AS CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
WE'RE GETTING BUSIER AND BUSIER.
AS WE SEE CLIMATE CHANGE HAVING
ITS IMPACTS
ON CALIFORNIA ON OUR COMMUNITIES
ON OUR POPULATION. AND ON OUR
RESOURCES WHICH YOU SO ABLY HAVE
REPRESENTED. WE DO HAVE I THINK
THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM UP PROBABLY IN THE
WORLD AN INFECTED DURING THE
THOMAS FIRE.
I RECALL SEEING A OF THE FIRE
OF PERSONAL FROM AUSTRALIA. AS
WELL AS PROBABLY BY TWENTY ONE
OTHER STATES WHO CAME TO THE AID
OF US IN.
IN BOTH NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OUT WHEN WE NEEDED IT
MOST BUT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE THOMAS FIRE
WE NEEDED IT IN DECEMBER NOT A
TIME WHEN WE ARE NORMALLY
EXPECTING OR PREPARED FOR THOSE
KINDS OF INCIDENTS SO. I THINK
THIS IS A VERY TIMELY.
DISCUSSION AND.
BY HAVING LIVED THROUGH THE THE
THOMAS FIRE AND THE SUBSEQUENT
MUD FLOWS THE MUD DEBRIS WHICH
TOOK TWENTY THREE LIVES TO OF
WHICH WE'VE YET TO FIND.
.
I IT IT IS A SOMBER. OF MOMENTS
BUT ONE OF GREAT APPRECIATION
FOR THE HARD WORK OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THOSE WHO HAVE. A
BROAD TO A TOGETHER THE FINEST
THAT WE HAVE AYE AND
DEMONSTRATED HOW GOVERNMENT AT
ITS BEST A REALLY DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE SO. WITH THAT I WANT
TO.
.
TO THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS I
LOOK FORWARD TO A TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE WHO. SUFFERED AS
WELL DURING THOSE. FIRES IN
OCTOBER THERE IS MUCH TO LEARN
AND GIVEN THAT THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY OF GOVERNMENT IS
THE PROTECTION OF ITS PEOPLE.
HEARINGS LIKE THIS BECOME EVEN
MORE AND MORE IMPORTANT SO WITH
THAT. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE HERE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORK. UP TO THE DISCUSSION HAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR AT
THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO.
INTRODUCE.
THE SENATOR FROM.
.
SO MY COUNTY.
SPECIFICALLY HAVING.
.
YOU'RE MEANT TO SEE NO SNOW
MCCOWN IN HIS DISTRICT SANTA WAS
CITY OF SANTA ROSA.
WHO HAS REALLY DONE AN AMAZING
JOB WORKING? YOU KNOW WITH THE
TEAM AND ALSO WITH HIS.
CONSTITUENTS CENTER MICHAEL ARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT CHURCH DOT
NINETY ONE.
SAY THANK YOU INCREDIBLE
PARTNERSHIP AND AND SENATOR DODD
HAS BEEN WORKING OVERTIME OVER
THESE PAST NEARLY SIX MONTHS.
BUT SINCE THE FIRES BROKE OUT IN
THE FOR NORTH BE COUNTY REGION
UNTS ONCE HE THINK YOU.
INCREDIBLE WORKING FOR ALL YOUR
EFFORTS ON ISSUES MUTUAL AID
ALONG WITH CHAIRWOMAN JACKSON.
UP FOR OLIVER INCREDIBLE WORK.
IN SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTY AREAS IT'S GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU. I'LL BE VERY QUICK NOW
AND I THINK WILL ECHO WHAT BOTH
SIDES CHAIRWOMAN TERMINATE SAID.
IS THAT CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A
MODEL A WHEN IT COMES FOR ME TOO
LATE SYSTEM. BUT ONE THING IS
CLEAR BUT THE SYSTEM IS STRAINED
THAT WE MUST ENHANCE FINDING AND
MODERNIZE PA THIS WORLD RENOWNED
SYSTEM.
AND THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
RESOURCES.
AT THE LOCAL OR STATE LEVELS TO
MOVE EQUIPMENT AND STAFF AT OUR
GREATEST TIMES OF NEED.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THERE
ARE APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND REQUESTS FOR MUTUALLY.
ELEVEN THOUSAND
OR THIRTY ONE PERCENT WENT
UNFILLED.
IT'S SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE IN
THIS ERA OF NEW NORMAL. BUT IN
THESE UNANSWERED CALLS HAVE
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES.
WITHIN THE FIRST TWELVE HOURS OF
THE NORTH BAY. FIRESTORM
BREAKING OUT OVER THREE HUNDRED
MUTUAL AID INCHEON'S REQUESTED
TO JOIN THE FIGHT.
BUT ONLY A HUNDRED THIRTY
ENGINES PERSON IN THOSE FIRST
TWELVE HOURS.
THAT'S THERE'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
CAPACITY WITHIN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM.
BUT MISTER CHAIR ALL WRAPPED UP
SAMENESS.
I BELIEVE A MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
REQUIRES AT LEAST A HUNDRED
MILLION MORE ANNUALLY IN ORDER
TO HANDLE THE INCREASINGLY
BURDENSOME STRAIN FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE UNDER IN
CALIFORNIA'S NEW NORMAL. WHILE
HUNDRED MILLION MAY BE A LOT TO
INVEST IT'S MUCH LESS THAN THE
NEARLY NINE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN INSURED LOSSES THAT ARE BEING
PAID OUT. IN THE FOR NORTH BAY
COUNTY REGION.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE DOZENS
OF LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST.
FORTY FOUR.
FORTY FOR THE NORTH BAY REGION.
AND IS ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO THE CHAIR ITS CHAIRWOMAN
FOR ALL YOUR CREDIBLE WORKING
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR IDEA
BACK TO.
CENTER JACKSON DUH Y. MIGHT
SEEM WOMEN.
IN IN UNIFORM HERE TODAY. ADO
Y. FOR THE RECORD TO KNOW THAT
MY DISTRICT THREE.
WOMAN OF THE YEAR IS NONE OTHER
THAN UNIT SHE FOR CAL FIRE SHANA
JONES WHO DID SUCH A FANTASTIC
JOB.
LEADING TROOPS.
YEAH THROUGHOUT.
THEN THE NORTH BAY FIRE SO WHAT.
WE ARE RECOGNIZING WOMEN THERE
DO SUCH A GREAT JOB FOR US HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE.
FIRST PANEL PLEASE.
I IT'S AN OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
AND I.
I CAN'T THINK OF TWO BETTER A
PEOPLE TO BE IN THIS PANEL THEN.
MARK YOUR DUTY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICE
AND CAMPAIGN WHAT DIRECTOR OF
CAL FIRE.
IT FOR THE RECORD IT'S IT IT'S
AMAZING I KNEW BOTH OF THESE
GENTLEMEN BEFORE BUT I. HAD NO
IDEA HOW WELL.
WE WOULD GET TO KNOW THESE.
.
AB MEMBERS OF ALL OUR PANEL
SUITOR COMING UP HERE TODAY SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GREAT SERVICE
NEAR GREAT WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE ON I IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DON.
THE WOMAN JACKSON GREAT SEE THIS
MORNING. OVER THE COMMITTEE.
SENATE MCGUIRE BE CF NOW BUT
WELL OF FIRST LET ME JUST SAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HOLD THIS
HEARING AND GIVE US.
.
SOME TIME TO TALK ABOUT.
REALLY WHAT IS.
WANNA CALIFORNIA'S.
ON GOLDEN RESOURCES AND THAT'S
THAT THEM THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW OUR OUR MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM GETS UTILIZED A LOT IN
AND IT REALLY DOES ENCOMPASS.
NOT JUST FIRE ALL THE WE'RE
GOING TO FOCUS ON FIRE TODAY BUT
REALLY ARE MUTUALLY SYSTEM. IS
IS AN ALL HAZARD.
CAPABILITY THAT ADDRESSES.
NOT JUST FIRE AND RESCUE BUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EMERGENCY MEDICAL. ON
AN EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
WE UTILIZE THIS SYSTEM PRETTY
MUCH EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
ON ONE KIND OF EVENT OR NEITHER
ON IT AT SOME LEVEL AND WHILE.
รณ YES HAS GOT THE OVERARCHING
RESPONSIBILITY IN.
INSURING FOR THAT THAT THAT THE
COORDINATION OF THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM IN THE MANAGEMENT.
WE COULD NOT DO IT WITHOUT AGRI
PARTNERS.
AT THE STATE LEVEL IN THIS.
BUT I CALL A ONE TEAM ONE FIGHT
EFFORT OF CERTAINLY. ON MY
PARTNER CHIEF PAM Y..
AND DATA AND CAL FIRE.
HIGH THEY ARE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL AND THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD HOW
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF BEING
ABLE TO ADDRESS THIS. BUT AS WE
MOVE DOWN THROUGH.
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THIS SYSTEM IS REALLY
OPERATIONAL BECAUSE OF.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND IT IS
REALLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
SYSTEM TO UTILIZE TO.
TO INSURE FOR JURISDICTION TO
JURISDICTION TO GET THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED ARE
WHEN THEY NEED THEM AND OUT IT
IS FLEXIBLE AND IT IS UP. IT IS.
EXPANDABLE GOT TO MEET ANY KIND
OF EVENT. ARE THAT WE'VE SEEN
THAT WE USE THAT THE SMALLEST
ADVANCE.
WE'VE USE IT PLANNED EVENTS
LIKE THE OLYMPICS AND OTHER
KINDS OF THE SUPERBOWL. ABA
WE'VE ALSO USE THAT AT A MAJOR
EVENTS LIKE UP LIKE THE FIRES
WE'VE JUST HAD.
BOB IT'S IMPORTANT NOTICES A BIT
OF A BACKGROUND THAT.
THE FIRE AND RESCUE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM IS AS OUTLINED IN A PLAN
OF FIRE RESCUE MERGE THE
MITCHELL A PLAN. THAT PLANS A
COMPONENT OF WHAT WE CALL THE
MASTER MUTUAL AID AGREEMENT.
BASS MUTUALLY AGREEMENT IS A
AGREEMENT THAT SIGNED BY BY THE
JURISDICTIONS OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN MOST EVERY. I CITY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALL EVERY STATE AGENCY ARE AND
IT TALKS ABOUT.
REALLY THE PREMISE IS NEIGHBOR
HELPING NEIGHBOR Y. JURISDICTION
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO ANOTHER
JURISDICTION.
AT TIME OF NEED AND IT'S DONE
SO OUT IN A VERY SYSTEMATIC INC
AND AND STANDARDIZED IN
COORDINATED.
IT WAS ALSO THE BASIS OF FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
STANDARDIZED EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM CALIFORNIA AND
ITS. AS A STATE IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
ACTUALLY HAS AS THE ENTERPRISE
THAT EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
THAT SYSTEM WAS THE BASSIST THAT
THAT BECAME THE UP THE NATIONAL
INCIDENT MEANS RESISTED THAT NOW
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN ALL
STATES USE ON. THE BILL THAT
MASS MUTUAL AID AGREEMENT FIRST
ADOPTED IN NINETEEN FIFTY HAS
CONTINUED TO PROVIDE. ALL FOR US
BUT WE KNOW.
AS SENATE MCGUIRE SAY THAT EACH
AND EVERY TIME WE LEARN BUT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO THINK ABOUT.
ARE MODERNIZING THE SYSTEM AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
.
THIS SYSTEM.
AS I MENTIONED IS ALL HAZARDS.
IT'S PREDICATED ON ON
LEVERAGING.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS LOCAL
ELECTED BODIES ABILITY TO
DECLARE LOCAL EMERGENCIES ARE
THE GOVERNOR BECAUSE ABILITY TO
PROCLAIM A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
AND OR A UTILIZING THE
PRESIDENT DECLARES A
PRESIDENTIAL.
.
BUT THE PRESIDENTIAL EMERGENCY.
R. IT ALSO SPEAKS TO CASES I
GOT FOR BED OF THE STATE OF WAR
ALL BUT ALSO FOR TERRORISM
RELATED TODD TYPES OF ACTIVITY
SO SECURITY.
THREATS THAT THE STATE AND ALL
OF THAT IS THE FIND ARE IN WHAT
WE HAVE IN STATUETTE CALLED
EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT.
HOW DOES THIS WORK SO THE THE
WAY THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED IS
THAT?
WHEN.
EVENTS EXCEED IN JURISDICTIONS
CAPABILITIES.
THAT THAT MUTUAL AID SYSTEM CAN
BE LEVERAGED TO ASCERTAIN THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED.
AND IT'S VERY FOCUSED ON THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
THAT JURISDICTION TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE WHATEVER CASE THEY'RE
DEALING WITH ARE IF BIG IF THE
IF THE EVENTS BECOME MORE
COMPLICATED IN SIZE AND SCOPE
AND SCALE.
THEN.
OR THE EVENTS REQUIRE INVOLVE
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS THAT CYST
THAT MUTUALLY SYSTEM IS ALLOWED
TO EXPAND AND.
AND THOSE THOSE RESOURCES ARE
OBTAINED.
THROUGH.
A SERIES OF OF A STANDARD ICE
PROCESS HE STARTING AT THE
LOCAL.
CITY LEVEL. OUGHT TO A.
WHAT WE CALL AN OPERATIONAL
AREA COORDINATOR IT SET COUNTY
COORDINATOR TYPICALLY A LOCAL
FIRE CHIEF?
BUT.
I THINK COULD BE SOMEWHAT LIKE
AN INCREASE TO CAL FIRE
SOMETIMES OPERATES THAT IN THE
INS IN THE IN THE UP AND UP.
REPRESENTING LOCAL FIRE AND THEN
IT GOES UP INTO A REGIONAL.
WHICH IS MULTIPLE COUNTIES
ALL WERE REGIONAL COORDINATORS
THEN I CAN LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE
RESOURCES THAT ARE BETTER
SITTING WITHIN.
A REGION SO THE THE.
THE OPERATIONAL AREA OR THE
COUNTY COORDINATOR IS LOOKING AT
RESOURCES THAT EXIST IN ALL THE
CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY. AND
THE REGIONAL COORDINATOR IS
LOOKING AT ALL THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE WITHIN. A MULTIPLE
COUNTIES WITHIN A REGION AND
THEN OF COURSE IF IT STILL.
NEEDED SPECIALIZED RESOURCES OR
THE SITUATION IS SO COMPLEX IT
COMES UP TO. A STATE WE ASK
HEADQUARTERS WHERE WE LOOK AT IT
FROM A STATEWIDE BASIS LOOKING
AT EVERY JURISDICTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND BEING ABLE TO
LITERALLY TAPI AND. TO ALL
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
THAT PARTICULAR INCIDENT ALL OF
THOSE RESOURCES
FROM THAT. CALIFORNIA MEXICAN
BORDER TO THE CALIFORNIA OREGON
BORDER ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
SYSTEM AND ALL OF THEM CAN BE.
PROVIDED TO A LOCAL FIRE CHIEF
IN THIS CONTEXT TO SUPPORT BAD
INCIDENT SO YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
A FIRE CHIEF WITHOUT FIRE
DEPARTMENT OF. THREE OR FOUR
STATIONS AND YOU KNOW EIGHTY
FIREFIGHTERS LITERALLY CAN HAVE
ON HIS BACK STEPS ALL WITHIN A
MATTER OF HOURS HUNDREDS OF
FIREFIGHTERS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
FIREFIGHTERS. BAD TO BE ABLE TO.
THE LEVERAGE THAT CAPABILITY.
AND.
AND THEN THE STATE CAN ALSO.
ARE AS SENATOR JACKSON MENTION
GO OUT OF STATE FOR OUT OF STATE
RESOURCES TO UP TO A VERY
SOPHISTICATED. CORE DATA PROCESS
AND AN INITIALLY INTERNATIONALLY
ARE AS WE DID.
IN THE NORTH BAY FIRES IN THIS
CASE WE HAD A NUMBER OF FIRE
UNITS FROM ALL OVER THE UNITED
STATES AYE WE ALSO HAVE FAR
UNITS HERE FROM AUSTRALIA.
BOB.
SO THE.
THE PLAN IS IS IS PUT IS PRETTY
SOLID IT IT PROVIDES FOR THAT
SYSTEMATIC MOBILIZATION LAW AND
ORGANIZATION OPERATION UP A FIRE
AND RESCUE IT'S NOT JUST.
FIREFIGHTING ASSETS HITS ITSELF
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRE EQUIPMENT.
ITS COMMUNICATIONS IT'S A
SEARCH AND RESCUE ITS SWIFT
WATER FLOOD RESCUE IT'S THE
GAMBIT HOW THIS MATERIALS THE
GAMUT OF RESOURCES THAT ARE CAP
THAT MODERN FIRE SERVICES. UP
PROVIDE FOR US AND I WILL TELL
YOU I AS YOU HEAR A WITH SOME
STATISTICAL AYE DATA W. PROVIDED
BY CHEAP PADLOCK.
IN THE CASE OF FIRE SPECIFIC.
ALL THAT THE THE REQUIREMENT HAS
INCREASED EXPONENTIALLY OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS UP OF THE NEED TO
TAP INTO THE SYSTEM BATCHES FOR
FIRE ALONE. WE HAVE ALSO
MOBILIZED IN THE IN THE MOST
RECENT YEARS FOR US SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT FLOODING
FOR OF COURSE UNFORTUNATELY THE
MUD. FLOWS IN SANTA BARBARA UP
FOR MAJOR HAZMAT INCIDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TRAIN
DERAILMENTS OTHER KINDS OF
EVENTS.
SO THE SYSTEM IS VERY VERY BUSY
IT'S COMPREHENSIVE IT'S
COMPATIBLE WITH THE STATE
EMERGENCY PLAN AND WITH OTHER
PLANTS ARE AT THE LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL LEVEL. ON ALL
JURISDICTIONS OPERATE UNDER
THOSE PLANS TO BE.
STATE FIRE RESCUE PLAN IS AN
ANNEX TO THIS TO THE STATE
EMERGENCY PLAN WHICH IS THE OVER
ARCHING. ALTHOUGH THE
JURISDICTIONS IN IN CALIFORNIA
ALL FALL UNDER THAT.
THAT PLAN.
BOB.
VERY POOR NOTE THAT.
THE THE PLAN ALSO ESTABLISHES
VERY.
SOPHISTICATED CAPABILITIES FOR
EACH JURISDICTION PROVIDING THE
ARE COUNTY OR OPERATIONAL AREA
COORDINATORS AND THE REGIONAL
COORDINATORS.
DAILY UP FIRE DEFENSE RESOURCE
INVENTORIES.
THEY ALSO TALK ABOUT HOW WHAT'S
AVAILABLE WHAT'S DOWN WHERE
THEY'RE LOCATED ARM AND THE
SYSTEM INCLUDES NOT JUST. MADE
UP OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE
ENGINES BUT ALSO INCLUDES OF
COURSE CAL FIRE ENGINES AND IT
INCLUDES.
KALPOE WE ASK OUR ENGINES WHICH
ARE A LAYER OF RESOURCES THAT
BET BET NO MATTER WHAT THE
INCIDENT IS IN CALIFORNIA NO
MATTER WHAT. THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT ARE IMPACTING ANY OF OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE WE KNOW AS
A STATE WE'VE GOT THESE FORCES
THAT CAN CONTAIN CAN ALWAYS BE
APPLIED AND THEY'RE ALL. THEY'RE
ALL RISK INJURED SO THEY CAN
HANDLE WHILE MEANDER STRUCTURE
HAZMAT THEY HAVE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL THEY HAVE URBAN SEARCH
AND RESCUE CAPABILITY ON.
AND.
.
AND WHILE WE'VE GOT ALL THESE
RESOURCES ARE AND THAT DATABASE
SYSTEM INTEGRITY IS REALLY MADE
UP OF OF AYE AYE DAVID DAY
COORDINATION WITH OUR LOCAL FIRE
CHIEFS.
A LOCAL FIRE AGENCIES ARE
REGIONAL COORDINATORS AND AND OF
COURSE OUR PARTNERS ACCOUNT FIRE
AND AS I MENTIONED THE OTHER
AGENCIES.
.
UP THE IMPACTS ON THE SYSTEM
HAVE BEEN. THOUGHT CONSIDERABLE
HARM I HAVE IN MY. THIRTY YEARS
HAVE NOT SEEN THE LEVEL OF
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THEM THAT AND THE AMOUNT OF
IMPACTS THAT WE HAVE SEEN. ARM
AND DOWN AND I KNOW WE'RE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY AND.
IMPORTANT THAT THAT MONITORS
MODERNIZATION OF THE SYSTEM.
IS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR IT TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION ONE I THINK
THERE'S A FEW AREAS OF THAT I'D
LIKE TO NOTE ABOUT
MODERNIZATION.
THE FIRST IS THAT DUMB AYE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
GETTING AYE HAVING THE ABILITY
TO GET REAL TIME REAL.
WHO?
UP A SITUATIONAL CONDITIONS AS
THEIR EVOLVING OR UNFOLDING IN
BEING ABLE TO GET THAT INTO THE.
AT EACH OF THESE LEVELS IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT THAT. ICQ I OFTEN
TALK ABOUT MEN BEING ABLE TO
STAY OUT IN FRONT OF EVOLVING
CRISIS AND ANY GRIEF ALL THE
DISASTERS BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU
LET THE DISASTER GET OUT IN
FRONT OF YOU. YOU ARE IN A
DEFENSIVE POSTURE YOU NEVER CAN
REALLY CATCH UP IF IT EXPANDS
EXPONENTIALLY WITH EACH HOUR SO
STAYING OUT IN FRONT OF A
DISASTER IS A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT FAKE.
THE WORK PICKED UP THE CHIEF PAM
WHAT I DO WITH WITH THE OTHER
PARTNERS IS. EARLY ON PASSED THE
NEED TO GET OUT IN FRONT I THINK
THIS IS PLAYED OUT AS YOU YOU
YOU WHAT YOU OBSERVED BUT IN
THIS LAST SERIES OF DISASTERS
WHERE WE WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY
TO TRY TO STAY OUT IN FRONT OF
THE.
EVOLVING SITUATION.
THE CASE.
WAS NOT POSSIBLE ARE IN THE
CASE OF THE NORTHERN FIRES THESE
FIRES IS THAT IS CAN WILL TELL
YOU WERE MOVING AT.
A AND UNBELIEVABLE RATE THEY
WERE EXTREME CONDITIONS AND YOU
KNOW HUMANLY POSSIBLE ABILITY
TO.
TO GET A RESOURCES IN THE RIGHT
PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
SO THAT SAID IF YOU CAN'T OUT
RUN IT YOU HAVE TO ANTICIPATED
AND ANTICIPATING IT IS USING
GOOD PREDICTIVE.
SERVICES LOOKING LOOKING AT THE
CONDITIONS AND THEN PRE
POSITIONING RESOURCES IN THE
RIGHT PLACE SO THAT THEIR
INITIAL ATTACK CAN GET IN AND
KEEP FIRE SMALL. AND WHEN YOU
GOT THESE BIG WIN VANCE YOU GOT
THESE VERY DANGEROUS CONDITIONS
WE'VE GOT RESOURCES PLACED
APPROPRIATELY IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE SO. PRE POSITIONING
IS A ONE OF THOSE AREAS BUT IT
CANNOT BE DONE WITHOUT GOOD
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS IS AN
IMPROVEMENT IN OUR TECHNOLOGY.
ARE IMPROVEMENT IN KNOWING WHERE
RESOURCES ARE LOCATED AT ANY
TIME THROUGH THINGS LIKE OUR
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATOR IT
SHOULDN'T AND OTHER KIND OF
RESOURCE.
COORDINATORS ABA.
WE WE ALSO OF OF A COUPLE YEARS
AGO AT A COLLABORATION WITH CAL
FIRE AND.
THE US DEPARTMENT HOMELAND
SECURITY CITED TEXT ALL
TECHNOLOGY DIRECTORATE.
STARTED TO WORK ON SOMETHING
CALLED THE NEXT GENERATION
INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM A THIS
IS A SITUATIONAL TOOL WEEK.
SCOUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA IF CIOS
FOR SITUATION AWARENESS
COLLABORATION TOOL AND THAT IT'S
A TOOL THAT IT IS NOW EVOLVING
ALL BUT BUT SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO INVEST MUCH MORE AND. I
THOUGHT THAT IS GIVING US SOME
OF THIS THIS THE SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS THAT I'M TALKING A.
I'M AND WE'RE DOING THIS IN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT WITH OUR
PART
AUSTRALIA ACTUALLY.
US BECAUSE THEY HAVEA VERY
SIMILAR KIND AWHILE SO WE'RE
LEARNING WILDFIRE THREATS WE'RE
LEARNING FROM THEM AS AS WELL AS
THEM ALERTING FROM EYES IN THAT
THAT BILLS THAT PARTNERSHIP. AND
IN IN SCOUT IS NOW BEING
UTILIZED IN A PROTOTYPE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE USE THAT. ARE IN
THE LAST THE OUT OF FIRES AND IT
IS PROVING TO BE REALLY A GREAT
TOOL IN ITS ITS CONTINUING TO
EVOLVE.
BOB.
SO WE TALK ABOUT OF TECHNOLOGY.
.
BUT MODERNISATION OUR REQUIRES
OF FORMALIZING THAT CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RESOURCES
NEEDS IN A TIMELY WAY OP
RESOURCE REQUESTING COMING TO A
STANDARD SYSTEM ENSURING THAT.
FOR THE YEARS TO COME IF YOU
THINK THAT THIS WAS BUILT IN
NINETEEN FIFTY AND HERE WE ARE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WERE STILL
USING THE SYSTEM IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON FOLKS LIKE US. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS THIS
SYSTEM IS STILL OPERATING IN THE
WAY IT WAS DESIGNED BUT IT'S
BETTER AND IT'S A BIG MEETING
THE NEED A FORTY FIFTY MILLION
PEOPLE WHATEVER CALLOUS
CALIFORNIA'S GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT. HERE IN THE COMING YEARS
WITH THE THREAT THE NEW THREAT
OF CLIMATE DRIVEN.
CONDITIONS THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN A LIKE THIS BEFORE BOMB SO
WITH THAT I WILL STOP HERE.
I I'M JUST POINT OUT THAT THIS
MAP ALL OUGHT TO LEFT ME HERE
DOES. POINT OUT THE STATE WE DO
BREAK THE STATE UP IN THE SIX
MUTUAL AID REGION'S THIS IS OUT
OF. THIS IS A.
THAT IS DONE SO THAT WE IT'S
QUANTIFIABLE EACH ONE OF THOSE
REGIONS ARE INCORPORATES A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES AND IT GIVES
US THE ABILITY TO MANAGE
RESOURCES IN A MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE WAY. BY BREAKING THEM
DOWN FROM YOU KNOW ALL THE
RESOURCES IN CALIFORNIA INTO
REGIONAL BITES OR.
OPERATIONAL BITES ARE BUT AGAIN
THE IT'S NOT UNCOMMON TO SEE IF
SAN DIEGO FIRE ENGINES ARE UP IN
SISKIYOU COUNTY OR OR OR VICE
VERSA IN FACT I ACT AS OPPOSED
BY SAYING THAT. DURING THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FIRES
BECAUSE WE WE WERE COMING
THROUGH AYE IN SANTA ROSA WE
NOTICE THAT I ANY ENGINE FROM I
THINK WAS GEYSER BILL.
WE'RE THANKS MARC GOOD MORNING.
SHARES DOT IN JACKSON MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CAN HAVE A LOT
THAT DIRECTOR CAL FIRE AND AGAIN
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AGAIN
TODAY. BUT TO ADDRESS YOU.
DIRECTOR KILLER DO G. REALLY
PAINT THE PICTURE AND I I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND IS
THAT IT IS AN ALL HAZARD ALL
RISK SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. IS
JUST THAT WILDFIRES ARE THE ONE
EMERGENCY AND DISASTER THAT
EARLY HAPPENING ALMOST EVERY
DAY.
ARE ALL TWELVE MONTHS OF THE
YEAR NOW SO IT IS A BIG HAS
BECOME THE WELL PRACTICED.
DISASTER THAT WE ARE ALL
RESPONDING TO EVERY DAY IN THIS
AND FOR MOST.
IN WHAT WE DO UP BUT IT'S ALSO
NOT JUST A LARGE DEVASTATING
FIRES THAT OCCURRED IN THE NORTH
BAY OR THE THOMAS FIRE ANOTHER
FIRES AND SO.
FOR ANYA
THAT THE MUTUALLY MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM RESPONSE TO.
IN WILDLAND FIRES IT'S
I DAILY.
RELATIONSHIP ABOUT ALL ABOUT
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS IN
COORDINATION WITH CAL FIRE.
ARE PROVIDING THE CLOSEST
RESOURCES INITIAL ATTACKING
EVERY NEW START.
BOB DURING THE PERIOD OF JULY.
FOURTH WEEK.
LAST YEAR BUT WE RECORDED SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
WILDLAND FIRES IN JUST ONE WEEK
AND I KNOW. I TESTIFIED LAST
WEEK IN A SIMILAR HEARING
LITERALLY THAT AVERAGES OUT TO
ONE NEW WILDLAND FIRE EVERY
FIFTEEN MINUTES ABOUT IN THE
STATE.
THAT TAKES AN ENTIRE TEAM AND
COORDINATED EFFORT TO STAY ON
TOP OF THAT OUR GOAL IT CAL
FIRE.
IS YOUR NINETY FIVE PERCENT THE
FIRES CONTAINED AT TEN ACRES OR
LESS AND WERE SUCCESSFULIN THAT
BECAUSE OF THIS PARTNERSHIP IN
TEAM. POP CLOSEST RESOURCE OF
ALL FIRE AGENCIES IN THE STATE
RESPONDING TO PUT THOSE FIRES
OUT.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH THE
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CONTINUING TO CHANGE TO WHILE WE
CONTINUE TO RAMP UP.
AND DO MORE WITH LESS OR WITH
WHAT WE HAVE.
AND ARE STILL SUCCESSFUL IN
THAT NINETY FIVE PERCENT BUT
THOSE FIVE PERCENT.
THAT ARE ESCAPING THOSE INITIAL
ATTACK EFFORTS BECAUSE OF
CONDITIONS OUT THERE WHETHER
FUEL. ARE BECOMING CATASTROPHIC
FIRES LIKE WE SAW IN THE NORTH
BAY. BOUGHT AND IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO IT IS CRITICAL.
THAT OUR SYSTEM AS WE TALK ABOUT
ALL THE IMPROVEMENTS ABOUT ALL
THAT FOREST MANAGEMENT ALL THE
RESPONSE ALL THE LAND USE
PLANNING ALL THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE. ALL OF THESE ELEMENTS
THAT NGUYEN INTO A NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF.
ADDRESSING THESE DISASTERS THAT
WERE ADDRESSING ALL OF THESE
THINGS AND THE RESPONSE A MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
IS KEY.
UP THERE AS YOU KNOW THE FROM AB
TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY FIFTEEN.
THE STATE EXPERIENCE STILL THE
WORST DROUGHT IN TWELVE HUNDRED
YEARS THE DRIEST CONDITIONS ARE
ON RECORD.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH BUT SHOULD
BE OF NO SURPRISE THAT HELLFIRE
WHICH IS THE LARGEST USER. OF
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN THE
STATE BECAUSE OF OUR WILD LAND.
MISSION AND THE NEED.
IN TWENTY TWELVE CAL FIREPLACE
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO REQUESTS.
TO THE SYSTEM FOR MUTUAL AID
THAT'S FIRE ENGINES ARE OVERHEAD
PERSONNEL A LOCAL GOVERNMENT WAS
ABLE TO STILL THREE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE.
OVERHEAD OR PROPOSITIONS
ASSIGNMENTS FOR US.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN.
CALIFORNIA REQUESTED ALMOST
TWELVE THOUSAND ELEVEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
REQUESTS.
WENT TO THE NEW DELAYED SYSTEM
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. THE
DEVASTATING VALLEY FIRE IN LEE
COUNTY AND IN BICU COUNTER IN.
CALAVERAS IN AMADOR THE BUTTE
FIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENT WAS ABLE
TO FILL UP SIX THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE OF THOSE
REQUESTS.
ARE THEY DUG DEEP INTO THE
SYSTEM THESE ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FIRE DEPARTMENTS FROM
ACROSS CALIFORNIA LARGE AND
SMALL. OF VOLUNTEER TO YOU KNOW
LOS ANGELES CITY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
WERE ABLE TO.
BUT THE BOOT STRAPS IT PUTS
THOSE COMMUNITIES AT RISK.
BUT PUT RESOURCES IN THE SYSTEM
ODD BECAUSE THEY BELIEVED IN THE
SYSTEM BUT AS THIS WORKLOAD
CONTINUES TO INCREASE AS WE SEE
CHANGING CONDITIONS AND. WERE
ALL NEEDING TO PUT MORE IN THE
FIRE FIGHT UP IT'S PLACING THE
SINGS
CREASING DEMAND. BUT ON THE
OVERALL SYSTEM A VERY TELLING
EYES TO WHAT'S OCCURRING OUT
THERE.
AS AS CHIEF BYRD DIRECTOR GALA
DUTY TALKED ABOUT OUT THERE ARE
A NUMBER. OF ELEMENTS OF THIS IN
THE SYSTEM THAT ARE GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO LOOK AT.
AS WE DO AND WE TALK ABOUT IT
AND NOT BE MAY BE A BIT BIASED
BUT WE CERTAINLY AGREE THAT OUR
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT IS
THE BEST IN THE WORLD BUT IT WAS
NEVER BUILT TO DEAL WITH THE
LEVEL OF ACTIVITY THE CONDITIONS
THAT WERE FACING IN THE AMOUNT?
OF THE RESPONSES AND THE AMOUNT
THAT WERE ASKING FOR FROM
EVERYBODY BUT IN THE SYSTEM.
SO SOME THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
KEY ARE AS MARK TALKED ABOUT THE
SITUATION AWARENESS TOOLS WE
HAVE TO NOT ONLY. A.
ENHANCEMENT DOT MOUNT OF
RESOURCES IN OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES OUT THERE BUT
IT'S WE HAVE TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT IN GETTING THOSE
RESOURCES. AND THAT'S LOOKING AT
THINGS LIKE AUTOMATIC VEHICLE
LOCATING CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY.
IN A THREE YEAR PROCESS OF
OUTFITTING EVERY ONE OF OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE VEHICLES WITH
THEM.
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATING SO
WE CAN NOW IDENTIFY WHERE EVERY
CAL FIRE VEHICLE IS.
IN REAL TIME AND DISPATCHED
THOSE RESOURCES.
RIGHT DIRECTLY FROM ONE OF OUR
TWENTY ONE EMERGENCY COMMAND
CENTERS AROUND THE STATE THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT.
SEAMLESS OPERATING PICTURE
ACROSS ALL OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES THAT
RESPONDING ALL OF THE.
YES RESOURCES THAT RESPONDED
BECAUSE WE NEED TO BE ABLE LOOK
AT EVERYTHING ON AN INCIDENT AT
THE CLOSEST RESOURCES THERE. ARE
A NUMBER OF NEW TOOLS LOOKING AT
REMOTELY PILOTED AIRCRAFT THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE MILITARY ASSETS HAVE
BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL.
LOOKING AT DE PROVIDING REAL
TIME IMAGERY FROM.
FROM ABOVE THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLOIT THAT BOTH IN
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AS WELL. AS THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THOSE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
GOING TO BE KEY.
GOING FORWARD INCLUDING.
POTENTIAL SATELLITE TO A DATA.
BUT WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT OUR
COMMAND CENTERS ACROSSTHE STATE
NOT JUST CAL FIRE BUT. ALL OF
OUR BUT WE HAS OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMAND CENTERS
BECAUSE ALL OF THESE CENTERS ARE
SUPPORTING TOGETHER.
ORGANIZING RESOURCES ARE NOT
JUST MANAGING THE EMERGENCIES
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS BUT
MANY OF THEM. I HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED AS A RESERVE
COORDINATION CENTERS TO MOBILIZE
RESOURCES TO MOVE OUTSIDE OF
THEIR OPERATIONAL A RECENT
DURING. THAT THEY ALL HAVE THE
CAPACITY THE TRAINING THE
EXPERTISE.
TO BE READY TO PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES WHERE WHEN THEY'RE
NEEDED BUT JOINT TRAINING ACROSS
THAT AL OF US TO ENSURE THAT
WERE ALL WHETHER ITS. STATE
FEDERAL LOCAL BUT WE'RE ALL ON
THE SAME PAGE BRAWL COORDINATING
RESOURCES AS WE RAMP UP AND
PROVIDE PRE DEPLOYMENT OF
RESOURCES.
IT'S IN A COORDINATED FASHION SO
THAT SEAMLESS AND AGAIN WE'RE
ALL IN IT TOGETHER MAKING THOSE
DECISIONS ARE TO GET THOSE
RESOURCES ARE OUT THERE. OUT WE
ALSO NEED TO LOOKING AT THAT
AGAIN MODERNIZING OUR RESOURCE
TRACKING SYSTEM CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS FIFTY PERCENT.
OF THE NATIONAL MOVEMENT OF
RESOURCES IN THE EXISTING
RESOURCE ORDER AND STATUS SING
SYSTEM FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
RESOURCES GET MOVED EVERY YEAR.
AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE ARE DRIVING THE
NEED THAT WE ALSO HAVE A NEED TO
BE PART OF THAT NATIONAL SYSTEM
BECAUSE. NATIONAL RESOURCES
COMMAND AND IT'S CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES LEAVE THE STATE BUT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S
RESPONSIVE TO CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS
AS WELL. THAT WE WILL ACTUALLY
NEED TO BE SITTING DOWN AT THE
TABLE ENSURE WE HAVE EVERYTHING
THAT WE NEED TO COORDINATE WHAT
GOES ON ALL HAZARD WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS. NOT YOUR
EXTERNALLY IN WORKING WITH ALL
OF OUR PARTNERS.
AND AS WE FOUND OUT.
PARTICULARLY IN THE NORTH BAY
FIRES BUT IN THE THOMAS FIRES
WELL WHETHER IS KEY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT WEATHER IS
DOING. WELL AS KEEN AS WE TALK
ABOUT SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
TOOLS.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
PREDICTIVE SERVICES WE HAVE A
BILL IDENTIFY WERE RED FLAG
CONDITIONS AND WINDS AND LOW
HUMIDITY HE'S.
BUT.
THE WEATHER FORECASTS THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT IN THE NORTH BAY
FIRES.
YOU KNOW THAT WEEKEND OF OCTOBER
SEVENTH AND EIGHTH IS A BROAD
AREA WE KNEW THAT WE HAD A BROAD
AREA. OF OF FIRE WHETHER.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE WORKING
TOREFINE OUR WEATHER FORECAST
GET
THEM DOWN TO THE MICRO LEVEL
WHERE WE CAN SO THAT WHEN WE
HAVE AN AREA LIKE MARK
WHISPERINGS. AND COFFEE PART
THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY THE
POTENTIAL UP FOR A NGUYEN
SERVICING.
AT A MUCH FINER SCALE NOT ONLY
CAN HELP IN THE PRE DEPLOYMENT
OF RESOURCES BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
THE OPPORTUNITIES. ARE TO TIE IN
WITH WARNING SYSTEMS AND OTHER
MEASURES THAT ARE OUT THERE.
.
IS A LOT THAT GOES ON WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT CAL FIRES TYPE ONE
INSTANT MANAGEMENT TEAMS THAT
ENGAGED IN PUT ALL ORGANIZED ALL
OF THESE FIRES IN THE NORTH BAY.
AND THE FIRES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALTOGETHER BRINGING
ALL OF THE RESOURCES TOGETHER
BUT THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS OUT
THERE AS WELL DURING THE NORTH
BAY FIRES THERE WERE THREE.
TYPE THREE INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
TEAMS DEPLOYED WITHIN THESE
INCIDENTS PRIMARILY STAFFED YOU
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DEPARTMENTS AND THEY WERE
ENGAGING IN SOME VERY TECHNICAL
CRITICAL.
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING SUPPORTING
THE RELOCATION AND OUT OF THE
CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
PATIENTS ARE AND RESIDENTS WHO
WAS A IT WAS A CRITICAL
POPULATION. UP THAT NEEDED A
VERY BAD CRITICAL LOGISTICS AND
PLANNING SUPPORT. THOSE TEAMS
DID THAT AS WELL AS OUR OTHER
MANAGING OTHER SMALLER FIRES
AROUND THE STATE. TO AGAIN OVER
ALL THIS IS ABOUT CAPACITY IT'S
ABOUT.
A GROUP OF.
FIRE AND EMERGENCY
PROFESSIONALS WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA TOGETHER. TO RAISE
THIS BAR AND MOVE US FORWARD.
AGAIN TO BE READY. FOR THE NEXT
DECADE AS WE CONTINUE TO SEE
THINGS CHANNELS OF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF QUESTIONS.
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU I'M
GONNA THINK BUG DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF YOU COMMENT AND I KNOW
THIS IS A FOCUS ON. MUTUAL AID
AND I WANT TO COMMEND THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO HAVE RESPONDED
TIME AFTER TIME.
AND NOT ONLY.
SAVING LIVES
CHIEF TO
UPON SOMETHING THAT. I WOULD
WANT TO KNOW IF WE CAN EXPAND
UPON AND MORE ON THE PREVENTION
SIDE OFF BEFORE WE NEED TO CALL
IN ALL THESE RESOURCES AND YOU
MENTIONED ONE THING THAT. HURT
CONGRESSMAN ON CARE MONDAY
MENTIONED AND TO LAST RICH FIRE.
BETTER MANAGEMENT OF OUR FORCED
AND ON WHERE WE IN THAT IF WE
CAN COORDINATE AND HAVE BETTER
FORCE MANAGEMENT I THINK.
WE COULD CURTAIL THE YOU KNOW
LONG BURNING FIRES AT MANY
FOLKS.
CONTINUE HONOR CONTRIBUTE SOLELY
TO.
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT IF WE'RE NOT
MANAGING THE FORCE WE HAVE THE
FUEL THERE AND THAT.
TO THE FAR SO OUR IS OUR
COORDINATION IN THE LOCAL OR
REGIONAL OR NOW.
FORCE
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP IMPROVE THAT
AREA.
BUDGET A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
IT IS YOU OFTEN IT WILL HEAR ME
SAY.
IT'S.
ALL TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX WE
OBVIOUSLY TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE.
PRE POSITIONING IN THE RESPONSE
AND THE TOOLS TO COORDINATE THE
RESPONSE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO
BE INVESTING IN.
FIRE PREVENTION FUELS TREATMENT.
ALL ALL THE ACTIVITIES TO TRY TO
BREAK THIS CYCLE OF CATASTROPHIC
DEVASTATING FIRES WHEN THEY DO.
OCCUR AND THAT INVOLVES A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT. ARE IN
OUR WILD LANDS IN OUR WHILE AN
URBAN INTERFACE AREAS THOSE
AREAS WHERE THE WILD LANDS MEET
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT.
AS WELL AS THE FOUR STOOD
COMMUNITIES THE AREAS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING A HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION TREES DEAD FROM.
EPIDEMIC OUTBREAKS OF INSECTS
BECAUSE OF. DROUGHT AND BECAUSE
OF THE CHANGING CONDITIONS WERE
SEEING. ARE IN THE CLIMATE OF IT
MEANS AN INVESTMENT IN THESE
AREAS IT MEANS GETTING OUT
AHEAD.
PUTTING MORE USE OF PRESCRIBED
FIRE OUT THERE WHERE WE CAN IT
MEANS MANAGING OUR FORESTS
THROUGH THINNING IT MEANS
HARVESTING TREES TO GIVE. IT
SOME RETURNS TO INVESTORS ARE
LANDOWNERS CAN REINVEST AND PUT
MORE WORK OUT ON THE GROUND THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE OF
INVESTED SO WELL IN CAP AND
TRADE FUNDING FOR FOREST HEALTH.
BY TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR THAT'S ALL GOING OUT
ALMOST ENTIRELY. OUGHT TO
SUPPORT EFFORTS OUT THROUGHOF
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS WHETHER THEY
BE FIRE DISTRICTS FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS LA AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS TO GET REAL WORK
DONE ON THE GROUND NOT ONLY IN
THE URBAN INTERFACE AREAS SUCH
AS WE SAW. PUBLICLY IN SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA COUNTIES
WERE THOSE BRUSH COVERED LANDS
MET THE HOUSES BUT ALSO IN OUR
FORCE DID LANDSCAPES IN THE
SIERRA.
AND IN THE COAST WHERE WE NEED
TO BE DOING IT AGAIN MORE FORCED
MANAGEMENT WORKS IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ALL OF THIS.
TOGETHER CAN TAKE LAND USE
PLANNING TO ENSURE THAT BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. BOB IS MORE
RESISTANT TO THESE KINDS OF
FIRES.
SENATE JACKSON.
THANK YOU AND AND A CENTER
BRADFORD I'VE THE BILL JUST ON
THIS SUBJECT VICTOR. JUST SO
HAPPENS S. B. TWELVE SO
SEE WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PLAN FOR THIS NEW NORMAL BETTER
TO THAT FOR ON THE PREVENTION
SIDE.
.
I OF A FEW QUESTIONS IF I MAY
THE FIRST THE IT IS SO. ARE ARE
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBES PART OF THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. AND WHAT IS
THE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE TRIBES
AS FAR CISCO'S THERE ARE.
THERE ARE TRIBES THAT ARE
BETTER UP PART OF THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM AND I.
TYPICALLY THAT. IT'S SORT AHEAD
MESS BECAUSE SOME TRIBES HAVE
THE WHERE WITH ALL TO HAVE
RESOURCES WITHIN THEIR. TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND SOME DON'T THE ONES THAT
DON'T TYPICALLY OBVIOUSLY DON'T
PARTICIPATE BUT WE'VE HAD.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THE TRIBES
THAT HAVE HAD DOWN.
FOR EXAMPLE THAT GUY GAMING I
DON'T EVEN KNOW FROM RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO PUT FIRE
DEPARTMENTS IN PLACE.
EACH OF THOSE TRIBES A WORK
WITH THE LOCAL ART COUNTY CHIEF
ORGANIZATION.
AND AS LONG AS THEY MEET THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE REQUIRED
OTHER ALLOWED TO COME IN AND WE
GIVEN.
US CALL A DESIGNATOR NUMBER AND
THEN WE WILL MOVE IN THROUGHOUT
THE SYSTEM.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE MIGHT TO TO
ENCOURAGE MORE COLLABORATION
WITH THE TRIBES OR DO YOU FEEL
THAT WE DON'T. GET THAT THERE
WERE COVERED AS IT IS.
WELL WE CAN ALWAYS YOU KNOW I
MEAN THERE'S ALWAYS UP BROWN FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN ANY TYPE OF A
COLLABORATION.
THAT AGAIN THAT THOSE TRIBES
THAT HAVE REALLY.
WHEN WE'VE USED THEM A LOT AND
A LOT OF CASES THEY DO BRING
RESOURCES TO THE TABLE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD
PARTNERSHIP BUT YOU KNOW WE
COULD CERTAINLY ALWAYS TRIED TO
LOOK FOR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT THOSE
GOING FORWARD HERE ARE.
CAN WE TALK A LOT ABOUT MONEY WE
NEED MONEY FOR THE SYSTEM BUT
HOWARD THE RESPONSE CALL SHARED
AMONG THE MUTUALLY JURISDICTIONS
I WAS HOOKED ON TODAY.
HOW WELL BE?
?
IT'S AN ASIAN QUESTION BECAUSE.
FUNDING SOURCES ARE CAN COME
FROM A VARIETY OF AREAS IT IT
REALLY DEPENDS UPON.
.
WHOSE ORDERING THE RESOURCE.
AND.
WANTED THE CONDITIONS THAT
EXIST.
DURING THAT PARTICULAR TIME SO.
FOR EXAMPLE IF FROM YOUR FATHER
ACCOUNT VIRUS IS MANAGING A FIRE
ON ON A STATE RESPONSIBILITY LEE
AND. THE IN THEIR ORDERING UP
RESOURCES IT SAYS CHEAP THAT
MUCH SAID WERE BIGGEST USER OF
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. ARE THERE
TAPPING INTO THAT SYSTEM AND.
.
IN THOSE CONDITIONS.
THE ABILITY FOR CAL FIRE TO
UTILIZE ITS FUNDING SOURCES TO
PAY. OFF THOSE RESOURCES EXIST
HOWEVER THAT SAID.
NOT MANY OF THESE CASES.
OUGHT MAY QUALIFY WHAT WE CALL
FIRE MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE GRANT
THE USER FEDERAL FUNDS.
THAT IT THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
COORDINATED THROUGH A WE ASK AND
IF THIS CRITERIA THAT IS MAD.
ITEM IT'S HIGHLY POP ALL
POSSIBLE THAT SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE LOW. RESPONSE
COST COULD BE COVERED UNDER
THAT.
THAT F. MAKE.
BET BENDERS THE CASE IF IT GOES
TO A STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
CALIFORNIA DISASTER ASSISTANCE
ACT FUNDING IS MADE AVAILABLE OR
FOR GOES TO A PRESIDENTIAL AYE
THEN STAFFORD ACT MONEY IS MADE
AVAILABLE SO. IS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES UP BUT
LET ME JUST PUT THE COPY OUT
THERE THAT.
THE MUTUAL AID THE MASTER MUTUAL
AID AGREEMENT AS IT IS DESIGNED.
IS IS UP HERE MASTER MUTUAL LATE
IS REALLY.
DESIGN IS NEIGHBOR HELPING
NEIGHBOR IT IS VOLUNTARY AND IT
IS A RECIPROCAL.
THERE IS NO DIRECT MONEY
ATTACHED TO A MASTER MUTILATE
SELL.
SOMETIMES.
JURISDICTIONS ARE HELPING OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WITH NO
EXPECTATION OF COST KNOWING THAT
MAYBE TODAY I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU MY ENGINES AND TOMORROW YOU
MAY NEED TO GIVE ME YOURS. BUT
WE GET IN THESE BIG LOGS SUSTAIN
OPERATIONS THEIR HOUSE TO BE A
FUNDING SOURCE AND THOSE OF THE
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES THAT
THEY CAN'T COME FROM.
SO IF WE ARE SEEING MORE AND
MORE MUTUAL AID CALLS WHERE A
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE. GOING
OUT TO HELP HELP ELSEWHERE AND
THEY THEMSELVES DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES WITHIN THEIR
OWN COMMUNITY.
.
AGAIN GOING FORWARD LOOKING
FORWARD IS THERE SOME SUGGESTION
YOU MIGHT HAVE AS TO. HOW WE
WANT ENCOURAGED MUTUAL AID BUT
THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE WHEN
THESE LOCAL AGENCIES LOOK AT
THEIR BOTTOM LINE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES TO COVER
THEIR OWN AREA AND THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
DO IT EITHER IS IS THERE
SOMETHING WE COULD DO GOING
FORWARD ON? THAT.
WELL I MEAN THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE HAVING NOW
PARTICULARLY.
AT YOU KNOW IF WE'RE SEEING A
I'M A POTENTIAL SCENARIO
EVOLVING WHERE WE WHERE IT LOOKS
LIKE A FIRE IS GOING TO A YOU
KNOW WE GET BIGGER OR GET THEM.
SEVERE IN A PARTICULAR AREA IS
BEING ABLE TO MOVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES AND BE
ABLE%
TO COVER THEIR COSTS IN IN THAT.
WILL BE CALLED THAT GOTTEN NAM.
BUT TIM HIS.
THE MOVE UP A COVER WE HAVE THE.
WEAKEST REPOSITIONING SORRY UP
REPOSITIONING RESOURCES.
AND.
THAT'S ONE AREA.
A A YOU KNOW.
GENERALLY.
.
ARE.
THERE ARE SOME DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAVE A LOT OF PERSONNEL BUT NOT
ENOUGH EQUIPMENT AND THERE'S
SOME DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE MORE
EQUIPMENT AND NOT ENOUGH
PERSONNEL. SO IN IT DOES
COTTAGES ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ACROSS OF OF THE VARIOUS
SPECTRUMS COULD HELP EITHER BY.
ADDING ADDITIONAL EQUIPMENT
INTO THE SYSTEM OUGHT TO BE ABLE
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS ARE ARE
CONTINUING TO AUGMENT THE OAS
ENGINE FLEET.
THAT IS SO THAT IS ACTUALLY UP
A PROGRAM THAT AS YOU KNOW OF
THOSE.
YES ENGINES ARE GIVEN TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT UNDER AN AGREEMENT
THAT WHEN THE STATE NEEDS THEM
THEN THEY DEPLOY THOSE. ODD THAT
HELPS AUGMENT THE SYSTEM AND
THEN THE ABILITY THROUGH GRANTS.
WHERE?
?
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE PERSONNEL
CAN ENHANCE THEIR.
THERE RIGHT RESOURCE
CAPABILITIES THAT THERE'S A
WHOLE VARIETY OF AREAS THAT I
THINK THAT WE COULD TALK ABOUT
YOU KNOW MOVING FORWARD WITH
LAST QUESTION.
HOW DOES THE INCIDENT COMMAND
STRUCTURE?
A CHANGES OUTSIDE RESOURCES ARE
BROUGHT IN AND OTHER WORDS.
S. THING SHIFT YOU HAVE MORE
MORE ENTITIES COMING AND
HELPING.
US WHO WHO'S IN CHARGE AND HOW
DOES IT WORK AT THAT POINT.
IT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
THAT'S WHERE AGAIN CALIFORNIA
WAS THE LEADER IN THIS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY AFTER WE HAD A
DECADE A VERY DODD DAMAGING
FIRES AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
UNDEVELOPED FIRE SCOPE ABOUT
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES. FOR OF
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZED FOR
EMERGENCIES BECAUSE WITH THAT.
DIFFERENT RADIO FREQUENCIES
DIFFERENT HOSE FITTINGS
WE WERE AND WE'VE HAD THREE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
FIGHTING THE SAME FIRE NOT EVEN
TALKING TO EACH OTHER NO COMMAND
WHATSOEVER. SO THE INCIDENT
COMMAND SYSTEM WAS DEVELOPED
WHICH IS NOW BEEN ADOPTED
NATIONALLY WHO DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER RESOURCES COMING IN FROM
THE STATE OF NEW YORK.
OR QUITE FRANKLY FROM AUSTRALIA.
BECAUSE MANY MANY COUNTRIES ARE
ARE BUYING INTO THE SYSTEM AS
WELL OF THIS JURISDICTIONS
HAVING RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
PIECE OF GROUND OR THAT
DISASTER.
BAHAR THE INCIDENT COMMANDER'S
IT CAN BE MANY.
THE CASE SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
MULTIPLE RESPONSIBILITIES WITHIN
ONE AT JURISDICTION THAT PIECE
OF GROUND TOUCHES. PROP STATE
FEDERAL AND LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY
AREAS OF EACH OF THOSE
JURISDICTIONS GET A SEAT AT THE
TABLE AS PART OF THE UNIFIED
COMMAND THEY EACH GET AN EQUAL
SAY. IN THE DECISIONS IN THE A
CONTROL OBJECTIVES THAT ARE
GOING ON FOR THAT EMERGENCY. ALL
OF THE RESOURCES COMING INTO
THAT EMERGENCY ARE ALL ORGANIZED
UNDER THOSE UNIFIED.
COMMANDERS AND I AS WE'VE SEEN
WE HAD HUNDREDS OF DIFFERENT
URISDICTIONS PROVIDING
RESOURCES TO THESE FIRES THEY
WERE ALL GROWING UP UNDER THE
UNDER ONE INCIDENT ACTION PLAN.
ALL POINTING TOWARDS THE
INCIDENT COMMANDER'S AND AGAIN
MULTIPLE UNIFIED COMMANDERS ALL
UNDER ONE GOVERNANCE ONE
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE
IN THOSE INCIDENT COMMANDERS ARE
COME THEY COME FROM THE STATE
THROUGH A WE S. OR ARE THEY
LOCAL WHO. THEN SORT OF EMERGE
AS THE CONTROLLING INFLUENCE
OVER THE SO THIS COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT TO IT'S A LITTLE OF ALL
OF THE ABOVE SO WITH AS A AS AN
EMERGENCY PROGRESSES AND WE'LL
TAKE A WILDLAND FIRE THAT. HAS
BEEN THE FIRE STARTS IN THE
AGENCIES RESPOND THAT AGENCY OR
AGENCIES HAVING JURISDICTION
WILL IMMEDIATELY TAKE COMMAND A
COULD BE THAT FIRE CAPTAIN ON
THAT FIRE ENGINE THAT'S FIRST
IN.
ULTIMATELY THE BATTALION CHIEFS
WILL RESPOND AND ORGANIZE THIS
EFFORT AND AND THOSE OF THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE AS
IT BECOMES MORE COMPLEX.
IF IT'S A CAL FIRE A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY VERY INCIDENT WE
WILL CONFER AND MAKE A DECISION
IF IT'S GOING TO BECOME. A MORE
COMPLEX TO BRING IN AN INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAM DOES INTENT
MANAGEMENT TEAMS ARE. CAL FIRE
LEAD HOWEVER THEY ARE INTER
AGENCY THERE ARE MEMBERS OF
OTHER DEPARTMENTS ABOUT BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE THAT ARE
PART OF THAT.
AND THAT COULD THEN TEAM UP
WITH.
A LOCAL ENTITY GOOD YOU KNOW.
MOST LIKELY HERE WHO ARE HERE
FROM CHIEF ARDENER LATER IN THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA HE WAS A
UNIFIED COMMANDER HE TIED IN.
WITH OUR I SEE.
ON THE TUBS FIRE THE SANTA ROSA
FIRES BECAUSE AGAIN HIS
JURISDICTION WAS INVOLVED IN SO
JUST BECAUSE IT'S A CAL FIRE
TEAM DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE ARE
OTHER INCIDENT COMMANDERS THAT
PLUGIN. ALL OF IT IS COORDINATED
A IN THE CASE OF THE THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES LAST YEAR'S
THROUGH. ABOUT THE STATE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER WE
SAT DOWN AT A TABLE AND
COORDINATED HOW WE WERE
DEPLOYING TEAMS WHERE THESE TYPE
THREE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TEAMS
WOULD BE DEPLOYED.
ALL OF THAT WAS DONE KIND OF
UNDER AN OVER ARCHING STATES.
RESPONSE IN COORDINATION.
WHICH BY THE WAY IS DESIGNED.
UNDER ABOUT ICS FORMAT SO AT
EVERY LEVEL. THE TERMINOLOGY IS
THE SAME THE THE UNDERSTANDING
WE LOOK AT ALL THE ACTION
REPORTS IT'S AN ACTION PLANS
THAT ARE COME UP. AND AT THE
STATE'S HIGHEST LEVEL WE HAVE
WHAT'S CALLED THE UNIFIED
COORDINATION GROUP ALL OF THESE
ARE UNIFIED SO THAT WE CAN
MAXIMIZE ALL THESE DIFFERENT
RESOURCES.
AND AND BE ABLE TO TO MAKE THAT
THE MOST APPROPRIATE DECISIONS.
SENATOR GAINES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
WANTED TO.
THANK THE CHAIR OF FOR PUTTING
THIS SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
TOGETHER.
AND.
.
AS HOPE THAT LAST YEAR'S
DEVASTATING FIRES.
WHERE AN ANOMALY AND THAT WE
NEVER SEE THOUSANDS OF HOMES
BURNED TO THE GROUND?
I WOULD NEVER HAVE TO DEAL WITH
SO MUCH LOS.
AND SO MANY FAMILIES DISPLACED
EVER AGAIN.
BUT THE SIMPLE TRUTH IS THAT WE
NEED BETTER FORCE MANAGEMENT OR
WE WILL SEE A REPEAT OF LAST
YEAR'S RUINOUS WILDFIRES ARE
FORCE ARE CLOGGED.
DECADES OF NEGLECT WITH MILLIONS
OF ACRES COVERED WITH THICK
LAYERS OF TENDER. JUST WAITING
TO EXPLODE.
BUT THE TREATMENT MORTALITY
CRISIS.
ARE BALLPARK PROBLEMS ARE LIKELY
TO GET WORSE.
UNLESS WE CAN UNDERTAKE A
MASSIVE FORCE CLEARING PROJECT
WILL ROB THESE FIRES. OF THE
FUEL THEY NEED TO DEVASTATE
COMMUNITIES BETTER FORCE
MANAGEMENT ALSO LEAST MORE
PRODUCTIVE WATERSHEDS.
WHICH HELPS IN TIMES OF DROUGHT
AND CAN HELP SUPPORT A THRIVING
BIOMASS SECTOR.
IN OUR STATE.
WHICH WOULD HELP GIVE VALUE TO
THE FORCE WAIT. WASTE AND CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN THEIR
STATE.
FOR THE TIMBER INDUSTRIES PINK
CRIPPLED BY OVER ZEALOUS
REGULATION.
ALL THAT WOULD MITIGATE OUR
PROBLEMS BUT NOT ELIMINATE AT
THEM SO TODAY'S HEARING IS OF
GREAT VALUE.
WITH THAT I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
OUR BRAVE FIRST RESPONDERS.
HE'S TRAINING TIRELESS WORK AN
INCREDIBLE BRAVERY TRULY MAKE
THEM LIFESAVING HEROES.
WE ALL OWE THEM OUR DEEPEST
GRATITUDE.
WE NEED TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
SUPPORT THEM INCREASE THEIR
SAFETY DURING THESE CRISES.
REGARDING NEXT STEPS ARE HOWEVER
WE INCORPORATING BIOMASS INTO
OUR NEW MORE FORCE MANAGEMENT
PLANS.
SO ABOUT BIOMASS IS OBVIOUSLY
ONE PIECE OF THE THE BIGGER.
TRY.
DISCUSSION TO BRING
INFRASTRUCTURE BACK TO OUR FORCE
DID COMMUNITIES SO THAT WE HAVE.
MEASURES IN PLACE TO TREAT THIS
THE VEGETATION AS YOU DISCUSS
AND AND AND.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A COMPLEX ISSUE.
BECAUSE BIOMASS OBVIOUSLY
REQUIRES BY BRINGING IT TO A
FACILITY. CO GENERATION.
EITHER HEAT OR ELECTRICITY AND
OF COURSE THERE NEEDS TO BE THE
PROCUREMENT ABOUT IF SOMEONE TO
BUY THAT ELECTRICITY OBVIOUSLY A
VERY COMPLEX SITUATION.
BUT IT'S CRITICAL AND IT'S ONE
OF THE KEY COMPONENTS FOR GOING
TO STEP UP OUR GAME AND
REINVESTING MANAGING ARE FORCED
TO NOT ONLY REDUCE THE THREAT
FROM FIRE. BUT ALL INCREASE THE
FORCED HEALTH SO WE DON'T HAVE A
EPIDEMIC LEVELS OF INSECTA
OUTBREAK BOB INFRASTRUCTURE IS
GOING TO BE KEY AND AND NOT JUST
BIOMASS BUT YOU KNOW I THE
ENTIRE. WOOD PROCESSING OF SWEET
OF OF INDUSTRY FROM FROM LUMBER
TO OTHER PRODUCTS.
ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL WE HAVE WE
CAN USE ALL THE HELP WE CAN GET
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK ON IT
SINCE I WAS ELECTED IN OH SEVEN.
AND NOTHING'S HAPPENED SO I'M
HOPING THAT WE CAN GET
COOPERATION ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS TO DO. WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO PROPERLY MANAGE OUR FORCE WE
HAD AN CORPS FIRING O. SEVEN THE
TAHOE BASIN WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE?
BUT THE FIRES DIDN'T KCK UP AND
BASICALLY BURN THE WHOLE BASIN
DOWN.
WILL BE LOST WELL I SAY ONLY
BUT WAS TWO AND FIFTY HOMES.
SO.
I'M JUST HOPING THAT WE CAN GET
A REAL ACTION THIS TIME I WANT
TO APPLAUD YOU FOR THE JOB THAT
YOU'VE DONE.
IN TERMS OF THE HORRENDOUS FIRES
THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR BUT I'M
VERY CONCERNED AND WORRIED.
ABOUT THE FUTURE AND THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO DO
IT RIGHT AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
DOING SO. THANK SENATOR IT I
WANNA KEEP FOCUSED ON.
.
THE. FIRST THE MUTUAL AID HERE
OF AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
I THINK WE COULD HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING JUST ON THAT AND
INSURANCE AND POWER AND.
IT ALL SORTS OF IT AND WE WILL.
BRADFORD FOR THE PURPOSE OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY BECAUSE IT WE
COULD WE COULD BE HERE.
AND A LOTTA. CENTER MCGUIRE.
IF YOU SO MUCH SHERMAN DARDEN.
I.
I THINK THAT.
I WILL SPEAK FOR ALL OF US SO TO
SPEAK FOR MYSELF I THINK THAT WE
ARE FACING THIS NEW REALITY. AYE
IN OVER THE LAST THIRTY SIX
MONTHS EVERY TIME WE SAY IT'S AN
ON PRESIDENT WHILE IN FIRE GETS
WORSE.
WE THE BALLOT FIRE WHICH THEN IT
WHICH ECLIPSE THE OPEN HILLS
FIRE. BUT WE THEN HAVE TO CLEAN
FIRE LAKE COUNTY WITHIN AT THE
NORTH BAY A FIRE STORM WHICH
WAS.
BEYOND THE PALE BUT IN THE WE
ALSO THE THOMAS FIRE.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO STOP
SAYING THAT THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED AND PREPARE FOR
WHAT OUR NEW REALLY TRULY IS.
AND THERE WERE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WERE ADVANCE ABOUT A DECADE
AGO VIA GOVERNOR'S BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION NOT AND I'M HOPING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ALL WORK TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE.
RESOLUTION TO SOME OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES TO THINK WE
ARE.
BOB WE'RE CONFRONTING OUR NEW
REALITY.
WISH TWENTY CENTURY SOLUTIONS
CURRENTLY WHEN WE ARE FACING IN
THIS NEW NORMAL THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SO COUPLE OF ITEMS.
SEWING DISPATCH
BUT SO IF WE'RE GONNA EXPAND
CAPACITY WITHIN THE SYSTEM. A
TRIGGERED A GEO DEI JUST
MENTIONED UPON YOU WE WENT OVER
THE POTENTIAL OF ENHANCING
MODERNIZING COMMUNICATION BUT A
POOR PUTTING. ADDITIONAL ENGINES
AND PERSONNEL AND SYSTEM OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SIDE WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE ABLE TO GET.
TO AND FROM AYE QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY. AND IF CAO FIRE IS
GOING TO BE EQUIPPING ALL OF
THEIR ENGINES OVER THE NEXT
THIRTY SIX MONTHS. OF WAY IF
TRACKING EQUIPMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS DIDN'T NEED TO
DO THE TO DO THE SAME SO TALK
ABOUT THAT SO THAT ONE TEAM ONE
FIGHT WHICH I LOVE IN YOUR APPS.
HOW DO WE EQUIP? THAT WHOLE
TEAM WITH THE SAME EQUIPMENT SO
EVERYONE IS DOING THE SAME THING
AT THE SAME TIME IF YOU ARE
TIRED TOUCH BACK DISPATCH AND
TRACKING.
BOB I MEAN.
EUROPE CORRECT.
THIS IS THAT IF THIS IS A.
HAVE TO PURCHASE A HOLISTIC
VIEW IT'S NOT JUST ENGINES IT'S
IT'S NOT JUST.
OR FIREFIGHTERS IT'S IT'S ARE
HAVING A CAPACITY WITHIN OUR.
OUR DISPATCHERS IT'S IT'S IT'S
SOMEHOW BEING. BOB OF MAKING
SURE THAT OUR COMMAND CENTERS
ARE. THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAVE
THE SAME SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
CUTTING EDGE I THINK IF IF IF
ANYTHING. ELSE REQUIRES CUTTING
EDGE TECHNOLOGY IT'S GOTTA BE
WHAT WE'RE DOING IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
AND.
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE ALSO NOT
CURRENTLY COME OUT WHICH HOLD
THE OTHER HEARING I'M SURE.
EXPANDING.
NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE IN
CALIFORNIA EXPANDING OUR OUR AND
UP AND UP UP REPEATING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS
BACKBONE THAT EXIST THROUGHOUT.
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY SOMETHING
YEARS OLD AND AND.
IN SOME AREAS IT'S IT'S BEEN
MODERNIZE IN SOME AREAS WERE
STILL WORKING WITH THE. DUCT
TAPE DIDN'T AND BALING WIRE AND
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
APPROACH THIS IN A HOLISTIC
VIEW.
SENATOR AND.
AND AND THAT IS NOT JUST
GETTING THE PERSONNEL ARE ITS
TRAINING THEM IT'S MAKING SURE
THEY UNDERSTAND.
THAT.
THAT WE ARE.
DEALING WITH A NEW REALITY UP
IT'S ALSO ENGAGING OUR PARTNERS
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR THERE IS
SOME TREMENDOUS CAPABILITY.
THAT.
THAT THEY HAVE IN AND OUT OF
THE EX CHIEF AND I HAVE BEEN
BEEN TALKING WITH SOME. PRIVATE
SECTOR COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING
HIGH LEVEL SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
WITHOUT OUR CAPABILITIES FOR THE
MILITARY WERE TRYING TO USE
MILITARY. TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER IT
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT THESE ARE ALL
GOING TO BE THINGS THAT THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON THEY NEED MONEY
TO DO THAT AND THEY NEED OF
FOCUS TO DO THAT AND.
AND LEADERSHIP TO BE ABLE TO
GET US THERE BUT I I BELIEVE
WE'RE ON THAT THAT TRACK AND AND
WITH YOUR HELP.
AND JUST LAST TWO QUESTIONS MR
CHURNED UP FOR A DISCO IN THERE
I JUST WANTED MOMENT EYES A
CHAIR IN THE TRUMAN DID A HIGH
IN THE BEGINNING TO SAY THANK
YOU TO TRIGGER DO CHEATING.
JAPAN WHAT UP PHENOMENAL
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK ACT AND
KNOW THAT THERE'S CAN BE A LOT
OF WORK AHEAD IN PARTICULAR FOR
TRIGGER DUTY IN THE CLEAN UP SO.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH. TO BOTH
YOU.
ON THE ISSUES.
TWO LAST QUESTIONS ON
REIMBURSEMENTS.
AND THEN ALSO TRAINING ON THE
GROUND.
I THINK ONE OF THE OTHER
CHALLENGES IS TRYING TO BE ARE
TO GET THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REIMBURSES QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
BUT AND I THINK THAT'S GONNA
DEBTS IN ITEM THAT NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT THROUGH LOOKING MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM. IN THE OTHER ITEM IS
AND I'M.
A LOOK AT IT AS A A RELATED ITEM
YOU'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
NEW REPORT THAT HAS. NOT COME
OUT SOME WITH SOME FINDINGS IN
REGARD TO THE COUNTY CINEMA AND
HAVING STANDARDIZED TRAINING ON
THE GROUND FOR THOSE EMERGENCY
MANAGERS AS WELL. WHETHER IT'S
KNOWING. ABOUT THE LATEST ON THE
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE I'D TO MAKING SURE
THAT THERE. IS A JOINT COMMAND
IN THE BEGINNING IF YOU DON'T
MIND TOUCHING BASE ON THOSE TWO
ITEMS IMMIGRANTS REIMBURSEMENTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THEN THAT.
I. NEED ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
CRITICALLY FOR EMERGENCY
MANAGERS.
WELL.
ON THE FARM.
ON THE CASE A REIMBURSEMENT I
MEAN REIMBURSEMENTS ALWAYS.
SOMETHING THAT WE.
.
STRIVE IN BUT ALL THIS COMES
THROUGH WE ASKED AND AND.
.
WE HAVE.
CONTINUALLY WORK TO.
ESTABLISH
PROGRAMS AND PROCESS TO
ACCELERATE THE PACE AT WHICH
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE MADE.
RECENTLY WE'VE WE'VE IN AND.
ENGAGED IN A MUCH MORE.
TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN CAPABILITY TO
DO THAT. ARM.
I THOUGHT THAT THERE IS STILL A
LEVEL OF.
.
I WHAT I WOULD SAY OLD SCHOOL IN
THAT YOU KNOW OUR FIRE ASSETS
ARE RESPONDING. BABY TO GET TO
THE END SAID THEY GO THROUGH
DEMOBILIZATION WHAT'S THE GO TO
DEMOBILIZATION THEY'VE GOTTA
FILL OUT WHAT WE CALL IN THAT
FORTY TWO IT'S A. HAND WRITTEN
PAPER WORK OUR. CHIEF OFFICERS
ON THE GROUND ARE COORDINATING
THIS BELT OUT PAPERWORK IT'S
BROUGHT BACK INTO A WE ASKED WE
GO THROUGH IT AND YOU TO GET
ALL.
THAT'S IN THE AREA THAT NEEDS TO
BE STREAMLINED.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
THE BOTTOM LINE SERIES THERE
HASN'T BEEN.
YOU DON'T FUNDING TO DO THAT
AND AND AND THE AND THE EMPHASIS
BUT. THAT'S ONE AREA TO
ACCELERATE THE PACE THAT WE GET
PEOPLE PAID NOW.
I'M BALLOTS WITH THE SAY THAT
THAT IT'S JUST UPS SHOT OUT TO
THE CREW THAT'S WORKING ON THIS
I MEAN THAT. THE FOLKS AT A WE
HAVE TO DO REIMBURSEMENT OUR WAY
TO WORKING NIGHT AND DAY IN AND
THEY PAY DAY TRIED XCELERATED
MANY PAYMENTS AS THEY. POSSIBLY
CAN NOW NOT ALL PAYMENTS ALSO
COME THROUGH THROUGH THE STATE
THERE ARE FEDERAL. PAYMENTS AND
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER CASE THAT
I THINK WE COULD TALK ABOUT
WHERE YOU GOT DIFFERENT PEOPLE
PLAYERS ARE UP PAYING. OUR
BIGGEST PAPERBACK SENATOR DODD'S
QUESTION HERB SENATOR JACKSCREWS
XIN WHO WHERE THE FUNDING COME
FROM.
.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT.
THEY'RE EASIER THIS IS ONE AREA
WHERE IT'S STILL IN SOME WAYS
ARE OLD SCHOOL AND THEY CAN BE I
IMPROVE ON THE CASE OF.
THIS IS NOT JUST EMERGENCY
MANAGERS LIKE I THINK.
.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE LOOK ALL
DISASTERS ARE LOCAL BASED THEY
START THEIR.
AND THEY AND THEIR.
AS MUCH AS THE STATE COMES IN
AND ALL OF US GET IMPACTED THE
ECONOMY THE STATE GETS IMPACTED
OUR RESEARCH GET ACTED.
DISASTERS HAPPEN WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE THEY GO TO CHURCH TO GO TO
SCHOOL ALL OF THESE THINGS AND
SO WE NEED TO TAKE OUT AND ACT
ACCOUNT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OVERALL NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A NEW
NORM.
ARM YOUR LOCAL ELECTED BODIES
YOUR EMERGENCY MANAGERS PERSONAL
PUTTING EMPHASIS ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT WOULD BE A GREAT STEP
FORWARD AND THAT'S A.
OVER THE YEARS IT'S BEEN HIT AND
MISS AS TO HOW MUCH EMPHASIS IS
PLACED ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
BUT EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT REALLY
TOUCHES A LOT OF DIFFERENT AREAS
AS YOU'VE ALL EXPERIENCED IN
THIS RECENT SET OF FIRES.
IT'S NOT JUST THE RESPONSE IF
THE RECOVERY AND ALL THE SOCIAL
ISSUES AND AS I SAY OFTEN THE
ACHILLES HEEL WITH ANY OF THESE
EVENTS IS REALLY THE RECOVERY.
SO WHILE WE RESPONDING IN USING
THAT MUTUAL AID CAPABILITY TO
PUT THE FIRES OUT. BESSIE
MUTUALLY CAPABILITY TO TO SOME
LEVEL IS USED TO DO THE RECOVERY
OPERATIONS.
THAT CAN ONLY BE DONE WITH A
STRONG LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND AND
THAT MEANS THAT YOUR LOCAL
EMERGENCY MANAGERS YOUR LOCAL
FIRE CHIEF YOUR LOCAL POLICE
CHIEFS. NEED TO BE COORDINATED
THAT NEED TO BE WELL TRADE AND
THAT ALSO STEPS INTO THE WHOLE
THING ABOUT.
PREVENTION AND PREPAREDNESS
ASKED OF. AGAIN BRAGGING TO IT'S
OFF TOPIC LAND USE PLANNING
WHERE WE SEEING THE CURRENT
THREATS.
DEPEND WHAT I TALK ABOUT THIS A
LOT BECAUSE IT DOES PLAY INTO
HOW WE DO RESOURCE ALLOCATION.
HAS TO WHAT ARE THE THREAT ZONES
IN COMMUNITIES AND AND AND.
EACH COMMUNITIES REQUIRED HAS A
HOUSE A MITIGATION PLAN THAT'S
PART OF THE GENERAL PLAN AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE UPDATED AND
THAT HAS A MITIGATION PLAN
SHOULD BE A DRIVING FACTOR. HAS
TO ONE OF THE POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES THAT COMMUNITY CAN
FACE. THAT IN ITSELF BUT IS PART
AND PARCEL OUGHT TO OVERALL OUR
TRAINING AT EVERY LEVEL AN
EMPHASIS ON EVERYTHING FROM
ALERT AND WARNING. TO A AND THE
SCIENCE BEHIND THAT WHAT IS THAT
MEAN A COMMUNITY. BUT ALSO IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT AND THAT'S I JUST
WANT TO SAY.
THIS IS NOT JUST A GOVERNMENT
SOLUTION THIS IS A PUBLIC
PRIVATE NON GOVERNMENTAL BUT
ALSO THE CITIZENS IF YOU LIVE IN
A WILDLAND. URBAN INNER MAKES
AREA YOU TWO LANE ROAD
SURROUNDED BY TREES. AND YOU
HEAR THAT THERE'S A RED FLAG
CONDITION IN THE NEXT TWENTY
FOUR HOURS YOU NEED TO HAVE A
FAMILY PLAN YOU NEED TO HAVE
YOUR VEHICLE PACKED READY TO GO.
NO WE'RE FAMILY'S GONNA BE
HAPPIER CAUGHT TECH INFORMATION
AND BE ABLE TO BE EMPOWERED TO%
MAKE ACTION FREEZE UP IT'S NOT
JUST GOING TO BE.
A GOVERNMENT SOLUTION SUB TOLD
ALLOF THAT IS PART OF PARTIAL
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE AS
PREPARED AS POSSIBLE INTEGER
TURKISH.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DIRECTOR KILLER DUCE CHIEF
PIMLOTT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
WE'RE GONNA START OUR SECOND
PANEL.
THE FIRST SPEAKER UP ON THE
SECOND TO A. PANELIST LE CHIEF
UP FOR SANTA ROSA FIRE
DEPARTMENT TONY GOZER WHO I
MIGHT ADD I THINK EXEMPLIFY
PARTICULARLY DURING THE EARLY
DAYS.
OF THE FIRE OF THE ONE TEAM ONE
FIGHT MENTALITY AN ATTITUDE I
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS.
.
SHE FOR VENTURA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT MARK LORENZ AND.
I FEEL LIKE I KNOW YOU I SAW YOU
ON TV SO MANY TIMES.
THE PRESIDENT A CALIFORNIA
MATCH BALL OF FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION JEFF CARMEN.
AND DARE OSBY CHAIR FIRE SCOPE.
GENTLEMAN.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
DALTON AND.
HANNAH BETH JACKSON FOR HAVING
US HERE IT'S A VERY VERY NICE TO
BE HERE I'LL JUST TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT MY LITTLE
STORY.
WAS GENERAL'S FIRE DEPARTMENT
AND I SAW ON OCTOBER EIGHTH.
WE DID HAVE ONE EVENT SANTA
ROSA.
FROM ABOUT SIX O'CLOCK IN THE
EVENING UNTIL ABOUT MIDNIGHT
I'LL TELL YOU THAT THIS.
EDUCATION FIRES ON ITS OWN
AND FOR STRUCTURE FIRES ON ITS
OWN ONE OF THOSE STRUCTURE FIRES
THREE ALARMS.
SO DURING THAT TIME FRAME.
THREE ALARM FIRE THAT WE
BROUGHT A LOT OF RESOURCE
ALREADY WE'RE ALREADY LEANING ON
MUTUAL AID.
.
BUT BEFORE THE TUBS FIRE EVEN.
CAME INTO TOWN BOWIE NOW RIGHT
AROUND THE SAME TIME IT WAS IT
STARTED.
SO I'LL TELL YOU I WAS A I CAME
INTO TOWN LATE.
GOT IN MY CAR I WENT TO THE THE
MAJOR ARM STRUCTURE FIRE IN
SANTA ROSA.
MY HEARD IT WAS A FIRE OVER BY
SAFARI WEST WHICH IS A MARK
SPRINGS DRAINAGE AREA.
AND I MEAN THE ESSENCE IN
COMPARISON WHOSE OVER THAT WE
GOT RICK IN VALLEY HERE WITH US
IN NEW AND THEY'RE WORKING FOR
US WE GOT SEBASTOPOL WE
ENFORCEABLE AND LOT OF OTHER
AGENCIES IN SANTA ROSA WORKING
ON OUR FIRE. IN OUR FIRE WAS HE
WAS MADE DIFFICULT BY THE WIND.
AT MY PARTICULAR HOUSE WASN'T
TOO WINDY AND DOWNTOWN SANTA
ROSA IT WAS VERY WINDY AND I WAS
BLOWN FIRE NEIGHBORHOOD SO
THAT'S WHY I WAS A THREE ALARM
FIRE.
I RESPONDED TO THE MARQUIS
DRAINAGE AREA AND TOLD READ
COMICS TODAY. ATTACHED IT TO THE
FIRE.
YOU STRUCTURE FIRES UP THEIR
ATTACH ME LET ME KNOW WHO'S
WHO'S RESPONDING WITH ME. THEY
HAD NO RECOLLECTION. HAVE NO
THAT NO IDEA THERE WAS A FIRE UP
THERE AND THEY TOLD ME THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY RECORD OF ANY
STRUCTURE FIRE.
SO THAT WAS A THAT WAS A RED
FLAG FROM YOU THINK WHAT'S GOING
ON IN OTHERS A FIRE OVER THERE.
MY DISPASSIONATE DOESN'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION PASSIVE THERE'S
NEEDS TO BE SOME COORDINATION
FROM THAT. DURING THAT TIME
THERE WAS FORTY STRIKE TEAMS
ORDERED.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ISN'T WHICH
STARTED ON TUBS LA.
OUR OPERATIONAL AREA WOULD SHE.
DIRECTOR GIL DUDE SHE AND KEEP
THEM ARE TALKED ABOUT. THEY
ORDERED OUR OUR OPERATIONAL AREA
ORDERED TWENTY FIVE STRIKE KINGS
ON TOP OF THE FORTY. A WIN
ANOTHER CHIEF OFFICER ORDER TEN
ON TOP OF THE TWENTY FIVE. AND
AND.
ABOUT ELEVEN FORTY FIVE I
RECALL THAT THE ENTIRE SANTA
ROSA FIRE DEPARTMENT. AND WASTE
AFTER I'M EVERYTHING THAT WE HAD
SOAKED EVERYTHING IT WAS CROSS
STAFF WE STAFFED UP. BY RESERVE
ENGINES WE STAFFED UP LEAVING
HAD AYE MECHANICS GO TO THE YARD
AND AND. BASICALLY STEAL OUR
FIRE ENGINE SO WE CAN STAFF
PHAM.
A BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING SERVICE
SO WE DID EVERYTHING WE COULD.
AND THE SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT AT THAT WE UNDERSTOOD THAT
THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY THERE WAS
A FIRE IN THE SAME AREA NINETEEN
SIXTYFOUR IT'S CALLED HANLEY
FIRE.
DEPENDING ON WHO YOU TALK TO IT
TOOK TWO AND A HALF TO THREE AND
A HALF DAYS TO GET TO SANTA
ROSA.
THIS FIRE THE TOES FIRE
BASICALLY BURN THE SAME
FOOTPRINT A LITTLE BIT MORE IT
TOOK FOUR AND A HALF HOURS TO
GET TO SANTA ROSA. AND I WAS
UNDER EXTREME.
WIND CONDITIONS AND AND THAT'S
ON TOP OF THE OUTLETS FIRE WHICH
NAPA COUNTY WAS EXPERIENCE AND
THAT'S ON TOP OF.
BY THE NUNS FIRE WHICH ISN'T ON
THE VALLEY WAS EXPERIENCING SO
WE HAD IT WE HAD A CHIEF OFFICER
TWO ENGINES RESPOND TO CINEMA
BALLOT FOR MUTUAL AID NOT
KNOWING THAT WE.
THE TUBS FIRE COMING AND SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE COMMUNICATION I WILL SAY
THAT. BUT SANTA RITA NOT CENTER
IS A BET THAT THE CALIFORNIA
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IT IS THE
BEST.
THERE THERE'S NOTHING BETTER.
IT NEEDS TO BE MORE NIMBLE AND
USED BORN.
WITHIN TWELVE TO TWENTY FOUR
HOURS WE START TO RESOURCES. I
REMEMBER THAT FIRST OPERATIONAL
BRIEFING THERE WAS I LOOKED OUT
OF CROWDS OF MEN WERE IN TROUBLE
WE GOT FIFTY FACES OUT HERE I
GOT THOUSANDS OF HOMES DOWN AND
AND CREWS IT PAT.
OUT THERE FOR A LONG.
AND THE NEXT DAY THERE WAS A LOT
MORE IF THE THIRD DAY HOLY
SMOKES NOW WE GOT A LITTLE CITY
HERE AND WERE ABLE TO DO WORK
AND THAT'S WHERE THE VALUE OF
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM COMES AND.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
CITY SANTA ROSA FROM SONOMA
COUNTY THE CINEMA VALLEY THAT
THAT PARTICIPATED IN THESE
FIRES.
WE NEED TO BE MORE NIMBLE ARE
AND THAT THE FIRST FEW HOURS OF
THESE INCIDENTS SO WE CAN GET
RESOURCES IN THERE AND REALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. IF WE WOULD
HAVE A.
PRE POSITIONED ENGINES THAT
WOULD HELP TO THAT WOULDN'T
SOLVE EVERYTHING BUT IT WOULD
HELP AND WE WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THAT. ABILITY I CAN TELL YOU
WHEN I STARTED THE SANTA ROSA
BRANCH HAS CAL FIRE WAS ON THE
NAPA SIDE.
TOM I HAD MY MY COMMAND POST WAS
IN AT THAT KMART.
WHICH IS NO LONGER THERE WITHIN
AN HOUR OF ME ESTABLISHING
COMMAND AT KMART AT A BUILDING
CATCH ON FIRE BASICALLY READ ON
THE OTHER SIDE A KMART. AND HAVE
ONE UNIT THAT I COULD SEND TO
STOP THIS FIRE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT HE HAD
JOURNEYS MOBILE HOME PARK GOING
OUT WE HAD A SAND ENGINES OVER
THERE TO PROTECT KAISER WHICH
WAS BEING EVACUATED WE HAVE
CENTER HOSPITAL WHERE TO PROTECT
BECAUSE. IT WAS BEEN IMPACTED BY
FIRE IN THESE FIRES ARE MOVE AND
SO QUICK IN TODAY'S WORLD. WE
NEED TO GET MUTUAL AID QUICKER
ON THE ROAD SO WE CAN MAKE THESE
TYPES OF IMPROVEMENTS.
ONE STORY.
AND FONG GROW VERY WE HAD A A
BUILDING WITH.
PRETTY HUNDRED HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE WE COULD EVACUATE.
SO WE PUT AMEND ONE WAY.
AND WE DID EVERYTHING WE COULD
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE AUDITING
CATCH ON FIRE ANALOGY ORDER IF
THIS IF THIS BONTA CATCHES ON
FIRE YOU LOSE OVER A HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
SO DON'T LET THREE AGENTS DID
THAT.
THREE ENGINES SO WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT. OF WHAT. THE FIRE FOLKS
DID IN THAT AREA. IN HOW THEY
RESPONDED THERE WASN'T A LOT OF.
THERE WAS NO EXTRA CAPACITY
OTHER THAN EVACUATE AND JUST TRY
TO GET AHEAD OF THIS FIRE COULD
YOU PROTECTING.
VITAL INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
THE CITY TRYING TO PROTECT LIVES
SAVED LIVES AND BACK AT THE SAME
TIME.
BUT THEN YOU KNOW TWENTY FOUR
HOURS FORTY EIGHT HOURS WE HAD A
LOT OF WIND CAL FIRE WAS
EXCELLENT. OBRZEG AVAIL WITH
INCIDENT COMMAND TEAM ONE I WAS
UNIFIED COMMAND WITH HIM.
HE'S A HE'S A GENTLEMAN AND A
SCHOLAR A RUPTURED ON OF THE
SAME WE HAD A GREAT PLAN. AND
THEY DID IT IS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT IS NOT JUST CAL FIRE IS
NOT JUST A CITY SANTA ROSA'S
NOTS KNOWN COUNTY IT'S EVERYONE
THAT ONE TEAM ONE FIVE
THAT WE ALL TRY.
LIVE UP TO HIDE TRULY BELIEVE IT
IT WAS SO THAT THEY HELP GETS
THERE IS JUST DOESN'T GET THERE
FAST ENOUGH FOR THE TYPES OF
FIRES WERE EXPERIENCING THAT WE
EXPERIENCED AND AND THE SOME OF
ALLEN SANTA ROSA AREA WITH THE
NUNS FIRE HAND.
AND NOW THE TIMES FIRE.
AND IT'S IT'S A DIFFERENT TIME
SO WE NEED APPROVED PRE POSITION
EQUIPMENT TO HELP WITH THAT.
AND IT IS A WHOLESALE YOU NOT
ONLY GET OFF TOPIC TOO MUCH BUT
IS.
WHOLESALE LOOK AT EVERYTHING YOU
KNOW YOU GOTTA LOOK AT
EVERYTHING VISITATION MANAGER
BUILDING BECAUSE LAND USE ALL OF
THAT. AYE BUT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO YOU TO HELP WITH
MUTUAL AID AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT TODAY SO
THANK YOU. THANKS CHIEF GOZER.
CHIEF WARRANTED.
WELCOME.
SENATOR DODD SENATOR JACKSON'S
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME IS MARK LAWRENSON
VENTURA COUNTY FIRE CHIEF.
AND.
IT CHIEF CUSTOMERS RIGHT THIS
SYSTEM WORKS PRETTY WELL AFTER
THE FIRST TWENTY FOUR HOURS BUT
THE REAL CHALLENGES IT IS DURING
WHAT WE CALL THE INITIAL ATTACK
STAGES SO I'M GONNA.
SHARE WITH YOU MY EXPERIENCE A
MENTOR COUNTY ENSURE A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT RIGHT LOOKS LIKE
IN.
THE REASON I SAY THAT IS AT THE
FIRE THE THOMAS FIRE WHICH
STARTED ON DECEMBER FOURTH OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
I COULD I COULD HAVE OCCURRED IN
A MORE PREPARED COMMUNITY YOU
LOOK AT THE ACTIONS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN IN ADVANCE WE HAVE.
.
I'D A DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAM
WITH A HUNDRED FOOT CLEARANCE
ITS SECOND A NINE IT'S
MANDATORY.
IT HAPPENS EVERYWHERE WE HAVE.
A READY SET GO PROGRAM TO
PREPARE AKIN UNITY. AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY WHEN WE
SEE FIRE WEATHER COMING WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO STAND UP
RESOURCES AND PRE POSITION THEM
AND WE DID THAT ON THE DAY OF
THE THOMAS FIRE AND THAT
MORNING.
AT EIGHT O'CLOCK IN DECEMBER
FOURTH WE STOOD UP ADDITIONAL
RATE RESOURCES THAT WERE EIGHTY
SEVEN PERCENT OVER OUR REGULAR
DAILY STAFFING. THAT'S FIRE
ENGINES ITS HAND CREWS IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL HELICOPTER AND
PROBABLY JUST AS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT IT WAS ALSO
DISPATCHERS IN OUR DISPATCH
CENTER SO WE. HAD ANTICIPATED
THIS.
NOW WHAT'S UNIQUE WITH US IS
THAT MOST OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIRE AGENCIES CANNOT DO THIS
THEY SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD IT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO DO
IT.
WE HAVE THE LUXURY BECAUSE WE
HAVE A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND CAL
FIRE. AND WE ARE A CONTRACT
COUNTY ONE OF SIX COUNTIES IN
THE STATE.
AND SO ITS NORMAL FOR US TO PRE
POSITION RESOURCES.
AND IT'S ALSO A NORMAL FOR US TO
GET REIMBURSED FOR THAT MAJORITY
OF THOSE THROUGH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE E. FUND.
LIKE I SAID MOST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DON'T HAVE THAT
LUXURY.
SO.
SIX TWENTY PM THAT NIGHT THE
FIRE OF ALL FIRES STARTED.
AND I GUESS THAT THE BEST THING
THAT I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
ANSWER IS DID IT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE RIGHT DID STANDING UP
RESOURCES BY EIGHTY SEVEN
PERCENT MAKE A DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE.
WHEN WE STAND UP RESOURCES OUR
INITIAL GOAL IS TO KEEP FIRE
SMALL BUT ON THAT DAY WE HAD
SIXTY MILE AN HOUR EAST WINDS
UNLIKE ANY WE'VE EVER SEEN WE
HAD SIX YEARS OF DROUGHT IN OUR
PART FEW BEDS ARE JUST
ABSOLUTELY DEAD.
AND.
.
SO YES IT'S OUR OUR GOAL IS TO
KEEP FIRE SMALL BUT WE RECOGNIZE
ALSO THAT.
WE CAN'T DO THAT IN EVERY
INSTANCE AND SO. ON OCCASIONS
LIKE THIS ONE WE HAVE TO CHANGE
ARE PRIORITIES AND NORMALLY WHEN
WE SEND FIRE ENGINES TO FIRE.
THEIR INITIAL GOAL IS TO PUT A
FILE A RING AROUND THE
PERIMETER.
IF WE HAVE IF WINDSOR TO
SIGNIFICANT ARE SECONDARY GOAL
IS GENERALLY TO GO OUT AND
DEFEND STRUCTURES IN THIS ONE
WAS JUST UNLIKE ANYTHING ELSE
WE'VE EVER SEEN IT TRAVELED.
FIFTEEN MILES IN THREE HOURS
FROM SANTA PAULA INTO THE CITY
OF VENTURA.
AND WHAT WE SAW OUR RESOURCES
DOING WAS.
NEITHER PRINTER CONTROL BOARD
STRUCTURE DEFENSE WHAT THEY WERE
REALLY DOING WAS ACTIVE RESCUES
AND SO THAT GOES BACK TO DID WE
MAKE A DIFFERENCE WHEAT WE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T PUT THAT FIRE
OUT EARLY AND THERE WAS NO WAY
FROM THE INITIAL IGNITION POINT
THAT WE WERE. EVER GONNA MAKE
ANY KIND OF HEADWAY ON THAT
FIRE.
BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES AND STRIKE TEAMS WE
HAD ONE SMALL A RURAL COMMUNITY
CALLED WHEELER CANYON THE FIRE
WAS IN THERE WITHIN AN HOUR.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAD IN THERE
WITH AN HOUR WE HAD A FULL
STRAIGHT TEAM OF ENGINES UP
THERE. INITIALLY GOING UP TO
PROTECT THAT COMMUNITY IN
DEFENSE STRUCTURES WHAT HAPPENED
AS AS A.
ONE OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS WAS
EVACUATING.
SHE CRASHED HER CAR AND AND
ENDED UP BEING BURNED OVER AND
DYING AND ENDED UP TRAPPING
PROBABLY ANOTHER FIFTEEN CARS
BEHIND HER AND SO WHAT ARE FIRE
ENGINES THAT WERE IN THERE DID
IS THEY. SHIFTED INTO ACTIVE
RESCUE MODE.
AND THEY WENT DOWN TO.
EVERYBODY WHO IS STUCK IN THERE
AND ABOUT TO BE OVERRUN AND IT
WAS IT WAS ALMOST LIKE A A
KINDERGARTEN DRILL EXERCISE THEY
PULLED OUT ONE OF THE ROPES OFF
THE ENGINE.
THEY HAD ALL OF THE CITIZENS
EVACUATE OTHER VEHICLES AND HOLD
ONTO THE ROPE AND THERE WERE
ZERO VISIBILITY. AND THEY LED
THEM TO SAFETY UP IN A.
A CORRAL THAT WAS JUST A PASSED
THE ROADWAY.
SO THE DIFFERENCE IT MADE AS IT
IS MY GUESS IS THAT A NUMBER OF
THOSE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE PERISHED
HAD WE NOT HAD. PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES IN THEIR EARLY TO DEAL
WITH THIS AND THAT THAT STORY
THAT HAPPENED THERE WHEELER
CANWEST'S WAS ALSO TRUE. IN THE
CITY OF VENTURA THAT WAS HIT.
I AM WITH A GIANT WALL OF FIRE
THREE HOURS LATER AND WE HAD
RESOURCES IN THEIR.
BOTH FROM PRE POSITIONING AND
ALSO.
WERE ALSO VERY FORTUNATE IN
THAT CHIEF OSBY WITH LA COUNTY
ALSO CONTRACT COUNTY HAD PRE
POSITIONED RESOURCES THERE AND
THEY DIDN'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
FIRE AND SO HE SENT HIS
RESOURCES THAT HE HAD PRE
POSITION UP TO US.
AND THEY WERE IN THERE IN THE
CITY OF INTERMITTENT TIME TO
HELP PROTECT SOME OF THE
STRUCTURES BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
ACTUALLY PROTECT THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
WE.
I HAD THE INCREDIBLE FIRE GROUND
COMMANDERS THAT SAW THAT THIS
FIRE BEHAVIOR WAS UNLIKE
ANYTHING HE HAD SEEN AND THEY
STARTED.
REQUESTING EVACUATIONS FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE CITY OF
VENTURA WITHIN THE FIRST HOUR.
I'M.
ED SAID IT WAS SUCH A
COMBINATION OF SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS FIRST BALL.
WE HAVE A REALLY WELL
COORDINATED SYSTEM IN OUR IN OUR
COUNTY WITH ALL OF THE FIRE
AGENCIES AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS AND OUR OH YES PARTNERS
THERE THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR.
ACTUALLY DOING THE REVERSE NINE
ONE ONE ACTIVATIONS HIM AND THEY
DID THAT EARLY WHICH IS GREAT.
.
SO WAS IT WAS VERY INTERESTING
THAT HIM AS A RESULT OF THIS
THERE WAS NO LOSS OF CIVILIAN
LIFE AND AS A RESULT OF NOT
EVACUATING WE DID HAVE THAT. THE
ACCIDENT THAT OCCURRED BUT.
REALLY WAS REMARKABLE IN THAT
RESPECT.
PARDON  OR ONE OF THE
THINGS SAID WE ARE ALSO FOCUSED
ON THROUGH THESE HEARINGS HERE
IS OUR MUTUAL AID SYSTEM IN SOME
CHALLENGES WE HAVEN'T ORDERING
AND IT'S INTERESTING WE'RE
PRETTY WELL PRACTICED IN VENTURA
COUNTY WE'VE EXPERIENCED.
SOME OF THE DELAYS AND CHOKE
POINTS IT A CORE OCCURRING ARE
MUTUALLY ORDERING SYSTEM AND SO
WHAT WE DO IS.
WE GENERALLY DON'T WAIT FOR THE
SYSTEM LIKE WE'VE.
CHIEF CUSTER'S RT RECOGNIZES THE
SYSTEM GETS.
IT'S PRETTY EFFECTIVE AFTER
TWENTY FOUR HOURS BUT DURING THE
INITIAL ATTACK STAGES.
IT'S A CHALLENGES A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE OUR DISPATCH CENTERS ARE
OVERTAXED WITH CALLS COMING IN.
AND THEY HAVE TO PLACE THE
ORDERS INTO THE ROSS SYSTEM THE
SYSTEM BY WHICH WE PLACE OUR
ORDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO.
WHAT WE DO IS WE'VE LEARNED OVER
TIME THAT WE DON'T WAIT FOR THE
SYSTEM TO WORK I KNOW CHIEF OZ
BE HAS RESOURCES IN CHIEF
PROCESS WITH DALY CITY HAS
RESOURCES AND ERIC PETERSON AND
CHIEF MARDUK MARSHALL IN KERN
COUNTY?
AND SO WE PHONE A FRIEND AND WE
WE GO OUTSIDE OF THE SYSTEM
TEMPORARILY BECAUSE. WE KNOW WE
HAVE SOMETHING TO DO IT RIGHT
HERE AND NOW ITS WE MADE PHONE
CALLS AND THEY SENT RESOURCES
AND WE GOT THEM INTO THAT.
SOMEWHAT CUMBERSOME SYSTEM
LATER.
.
BUT I I THINK WHAT THAT DOES IS
IT POINTS OUT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THE SYSTEM IS GOOD BUT
THERE ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE. WELL OBVIOUSLY WE NEED TO
AND AS PRIDE NOT JUST
TECHNOLOGICAL.
AGAIN WE WERE FORTUNATE ON
DECEMBER FOURTH. HAVE STAFFED UP
IN OUR DISPATCH CENTER.
SO THAT'S A CRITICAL PART IN AND
AND BY LUCK.
YEAH I'M THE THOMAS FIRE STARTED
JUST BUT BEFORE SHIFT CHANGE FOR
US OUR DISPATCH CENTER SO WE
ACTUALLY WERE DOUBLE STAFF
WOULDN'T ALLOW ANYONE TO GO HOME
AND WE WERE ALLOWED IN ABLE TO
PROCESS THOSE ORDERS THROUGH
SYSTEM BUT STILL THE SYSTEM
SLOW.
SO WE MAKE PHONE CALLS WE WE
WORK AROUND THE SYSTEM.
SO THERE SUCCESS THERE AT THE
PRE POSITIONING SUCH A POWERFUL
TOOL IT IT ALLOWS US TO GET IN
AND TAKE EFFECTIVE ACTIONS EARLY
ON AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO SAVE EVERYTHING BUT. IT'S A
IT'S A COMBINATION OF OF
PREPARATION ADVANCE WITH YOUR
COMMUNITIES IN YOUR CONSTRUCTION
YOUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND WE
HAVE AN ACTIVE PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM IN OUR COUNTY TO. ITS A
COMBINATION OF ALL THOSE THINGS
BUT.
RESOURCES IS IS REALLY WHERE
CAPTAIN AND IT DOESN'T JUST
APPLY THE WILDLAND FIRES.
THIS CASE IN POINT.
NOW THE NIGHT BEFORE THE MODESTY
OF TRAGEDY IN THE MUD FLOWS.
OH YES STAFFED UP SOME RESOURCES
AS DID WE WERE ALL RISK WE
STAFFED UP. AND URBAN SEARCH AND
RESCUE TEAM AND A SWIFT WATER
RESCUE TEAM AND HEAVY EQUIPMENT
TO DEAL WITH WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS
CAN BE A LOCAL EMERGENCY. TURNED
OUT IT WAS AN EMERGENCY JUST TO
THE NORTH OF ASSN WE SENT ALL
THOSE RESOURCES HAVE TO MANSIO.
SO. BUT THE PREPRINT POSITION
HAS SUCH INCREDIBLE POWER AND
VALUE. AND IT'S.
YEAH I WOULD SAY IT'S AN
INSURANCE POLICY. IT'S EXPENSIVE
BUT NOT NEARLY AS EXPENSIVE AS
THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT BEING
PREPARED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SENATORS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S
JEFF CARMEN ON THE FIRE CHIEF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO REPRESENT NOT ONLY.
MY ACTIONS DURING THESE FIRES
BUT ALSO THE OF USE OF THAT
CALIFORNIA METROPOLITAN FIRE
CHIEFS. I'M I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A
LITTLE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE AS
MY COLLEAGUES DID AND THAT IS
THE PERSPECTIVE OF BEING A FIRE
CHIEF IN CONTRAST TO COUNTY ONE
OF THE EAST BAY. COUNTIES AND
AND BEING RECOGNIZED AS A
RESOURCE RICH AREA THAT IS
TYPICALLY DEPENDENT ON TO SEND
RESOURCES BOTH NORTH AND SOUTH
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE FIRES
WERE. IN THE NORTH BAY FIRES.
.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO OFFER THAT
WE HAD RESOURCES STOOD UP RATE
AGO WE RECOGNIZE VERY EARLY
EARLY ON OUR OUR. OUR COMMANDERS
THAT WERE ON DUTY THE NIGHT THE
FIRE STARTED RECOGNIZE THE NEED
FOR RESOURCES AND WE STOOD UP
RESOURCES ORDER FOR HOURS.
AND.
THAT WAS AS FRUSTRATING AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE WE COULD HEAR THE
INCIDENT COMMANDERS IN THE NORTH
BAY FIRES ASKING FOR RESOURCES
AND WE WERE UNABLE THIS TO SEND
THEM. UP OPERATING WITHIN THE
SYSTEM AND AND THAT.
WAS BASED ON TWO SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES FIRST HALL ONE OF THE
CHOKE POINTS WAS THE FACT THAT
THE DISPATCH CENTERS WERE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ADDITIONAL
DISPATCHERS ON DUTY TO.
A SIMBOLOS RESOURCES AS YOU
HEARD A DIRECTOR GALLUCCI SAID
IT'S THOSE DISPATCHERS
RESPONSIBILITY TO ASSEMBLE THOSE
STRIKE TEAMS IN THOSE RESOURCES
AND THE.
EARLY STAGES THE OF THESE FIRES
AND THOSE PERSONNEL JUST ONE
AVAILABLE THE SECOND CHOKE POINT
IN THE SYSTEM IS AS AS CHIEF
WARREN'S AND SAID. WERE
OPERATING UNDER A FIFTY YEAR OLD
SYSTEM.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED IN THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS AND AND BEFORE WE
DEPENDED ON THAT MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM TO GET US RESOURCES IN
THE FIRST TWELVE THE TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. NOW WE NEED THOSE
RESOURCES IN THE FIRST MINUTES
TO HOURS OF THIS INCIDENT AND
THE SYSTEM JUST QUICKLY BECOMES
OVERWHELMED SO NOT ONLY WERE
THERE NOT ENOUGH DISPATCHERS.
BUT THE SYSTEM CHOKE DOWN VERY
QUICKLY WHERE WE WERE UNABLE TO
GET AN ORDER.
SO THAT WE CAN SEND OUR
RESOURCES THAT WE HAD ASSEMBLED.
AND AND OUR GOAL WAS TO FOLLOW
THAT SYSTEM AS WE HAVE FOR THE
LAST FOR ME YOU FOR THE LAST
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. AND AND NOT
SEND RESOURCES WITHOUT IN ORDER.
NAM WHERE IN A POSITION RIGHT
NOW WHERE IT'S I I CALLED THE
TRADE FECHTER I THINK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THE LOWEST
NUMBER RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE
DUE TO THE RECESSION AND OTHER.
REVENUE ISSUES AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAVE FIRES THAT ARE BURNING
FASTER THAN ANY FIRES WE'VE THAT
WE'VE EVER SEEN THE HORROR
NOVEL.
CAPITALIZE ON WHAT'S SENATE
MCGUIRE SAID EARLIER HOW LONG WE
GONNA CALL THESE FIRES
UNPRECEDENTED WHEN WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THEM YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR SOON THEY'LL THEY
SHOULD BECOME THE NORM. SO HAVE
THE FEWEST NUMBER RESOURCES
WE HAVE THE FASTEST BURNING
FIRES THAT WE'VE EVER SEEN AND
WE HAVE A FIFTY YEAR OLD SYSTEM
TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH THOSE BIG
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES.
WHEN THE THOMAS FIRE OCCURRED.
SEVERAL HOURS INTO THE INCIDENT
I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WHO WHO SAID THAT
THEY WERE? NEEDING RESOURCES
BADLY AGAIN I HAD RESOURCES
STOOD UP READY TO GO I COULD NOT
GET IN ORDER IN THE SYSTEM.
.
AYE CHIEF TO RE UNITE FIRE
CHIEF ALONG BEACH MADE THE
DECISION THAT WE WERE GOING TO
PUT OUR RESOURCES ON THE ROAD.
AND SENATE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT IN ORDER BECAUSE OF THE
FRUSTRATION WE EXPERIENCE IN THE
NORTH BAY FIRES AND AND LATER I
FOUND OUT HIS TWO FRIENDS IN
JUST TESTIFIED. THAT'S THE NORM
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THEY'VE
LEARNED WAYS TO GET OUTSIDE OF
THE SYSTEM TO GET RESOURCES
MOVING.
IN ORDER TO AGAIN TAKE TO GET
THOSE RESOURCES AS FAST AS THEY
NEED SO. I I'M I'M HERE TODAY TO
SAY WE NEED TO MAKE SOME CHANGES
HANNAH AND WHILE I WILL AGREE
IT'S A MODEL SYSTEM BUT IT NEEDS
CHANGE. FIRST AND FOREMOST THE
PRE POSITIONING OF RESOURCES IS
VITAL.
THOSE THOUGH IT WENT WHEN WE SAY
THE PRE POSITIONING OF RESOURCES
WHAT WE MEAN IS. WE RECOGNIZE
OUR PREDICTIVE SERVICES ARE GOOD
SURE THEY CAN GET BETTER BUT WE
KNOW IN ADVANCE WELL IN ADVANCE
OF THE WIND EVENT OCCURRING FOR
EXAMPLE. AND AND WE CAN IDENTIFY
THOSE RESOURCES THAT WE WANT TO
STAFF UP AND PUT IN THOSE AREAS
WHERE WE'RE GOING I NEED HIM THE
MOST. THOSE SYSTEMS KEEP THAT
I'M SORRY THOSE RESOURCES CAN BE
USED FOR SMALLER FIRES TO KEEP
THEM SMALL AS AS THAT CHIEF
TEMAS SAID THAT'S THAT'S THAT
HAVE VERY IMPORTANT PIECES TO
KEEP THOSE FIRE SMALL WE CAN DO
THAT WITH THOSE.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES SET UP IN
THE SYSTEM AND WHEN THE BIG
EVENT OCCURS THERE ALREADY
WITHIN OUR RESOURCE ORDERING
SYSTEM SO THERE'S NO PROCESSING
TIME WE CAN JUST QUICKLY
IDENTIFY THE FIRE THE NEEDS
THOSE RESOURCES.
VERY CRITICAL COMPONENT OF WHAT
WE'RE HERE TO ASK YOU FOR TODAY
IS FUNDING FOR THE PRE
POSITIONING OF RESOURCES AHEAD
OF THESE CLIMATE DRIVEN EVENTS.
SECONDLY WE NEED TO NOT ONLY
MOVE FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRE
ENGINES BUT WE NEED TO PUT.
ADDITIONAL DISPATCHERS IN THESE
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS KNOWING
THAT WHETHER NOT THERE'S A BIG
FIRE NOT DAY ARE GOING TO BE
PROCESSING A LARGE NUMBER OF
CALLS. AND IF THE BIG ONE OCCURS
IN IN THAT CLUSTER OF CALLS SO
WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
EXPERIENCE. THEN WE HAVE THAT
ADDITIONAL STAFFING TO HANDLE
THAT AND STREAMLINE THE SYSTEM
AND LASTLY I WILL SAY THAT THE
RAS ORDERING SYSTEM.
IT'S NO SECRET THAT'S A
CUMBERSOME DIFFICULT SYSTEM TO
NAVIGATE.
I AYE AS IT HAS CHIEF PIMLOTT
TESTIFIED EARLIER. IT DOES
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS IN OUR STATE PARTNERS
WE NEED SOME
IT WORKS.
WELL AT THE STATE AND LOCAL
LEVEL AND THEN WE CAN WORRY
ABOUT OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS NOW
THAT'S MY OPINION SPEAKING FROM
A LOCAL FIRE SHE'S PERSPECTIVE.
WE NEED A SYSTEM TO GET
RESOURCES ON THE ROAD SOONER
THAN LATER SO. I'M JUST I'M
SIMPLY GOING TO RECAP MY
COMMENTS BY SAYING FIFTY YEAR
OLD SYSTEM YES IT'S A MODEL BUT
FIFTY YEAR OLD ANYTHING NEEDS
UPDATING.
PROBABLY INCLUDING MYSELF. WE
NEED WE NEED MORE DISPATCHERS WE
NEED.
PRE DEPLOYED RESOURCES SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT TO CATCH
UP WITH THE ORDER PROCESS.
SO WE CAN MOVE THOSE RESOURCES
TO THE AREA OF NEED. WITHIN
HOURS NOT I MEAN WITHIN MINUTES
TO HOURS NOT TWELVE TO TWENTY
FOUR HOURS. AND AND THAT'LL BE
THAT TOTAL AT TO TALLY OF MY
COMMENTS TODAY AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
DUCKS.
GOOD MORNING.
HONORABLE CHAIRS.
OF COMPACT DRIVE COMMITTEE MONEY
MR OSBY.
AND I'M THE.
CHAIRPERSON OF HARSCO BOAT
SPEAKING THAT PERSPECTIVE. PER
MINUTE.
AND I WAS SEVERAL THE HATS TO
NOTICE.
FOLLOW FOR MY PARTICIPATING
ALLOW MY SPEAKING POINTS. OF.
BUT THE. POINT IS RIGHT I AM
THE.
THE UMP CHAIR OF FAR SCOPE THOSE
IN OPPOSITION WAS FOUNDED IN THE
SEVENTIES.
IT'S THE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
FAR FAR ENTITIES CITY CALIFORNIA
THERE.
COME TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH A
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. IT'S A
COMMAND SYSTEM STANDARDS AND
TRAINING WITH A CALIFORNIA AND
WHERE ADVISORY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
EFFECTIVE MATTERS THAT WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT. THIS ORDER THIS WAS
FOUND IN THE SEVENTIES IS NOT I
DON'T KNOW ANOMALY AS IT RELATES
TO WILDLAND FIRES. EVERY DECADE
WE HAVE A MAJOR INCIDENT IN
EVERY DECADE WE COME BACK
TOGETHER TO TALK ABOUT.
WHAT WENT WRONG AND WHAT CAN WE
DO TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM? SO
THIS IS GOING TO BE ONGOING FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE INTO THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
SWITCHING CAPS I'M ALSO THE
REGION ONE COORDINATOR FOR
REGION ONE I KNOW THAT.
PROP PREVIOUS PRESENTATION TO
TALK ABOUT THE. THEIR SIX
REASONS THAT WITHIN A
CALIFORNIA.
AS THE FIRE CHIEF OF WATSON'S
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT I'M MOST
THE REGIONAL COORDINATOR. AND
THOSE ARE FOR THE COUNTIES OF
ORANGES LOS ANGELES.
A VENTURA SANTA BARBARA AND SAN
LUIS OBISPO. SOME FORTUNIO
TRYING TO SUPPORT MY PARTNER
HERE. HOW ABOUT THAT FOR THE
THOMAS FIRED? ABOUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS I'VE BEEN SITTING HERE
LISTENING TO. AS THE REASON ONE
COORDINATOR AND LIST WE HEARD
ABOUT. THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL DISPATCHERS.
I'M FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AS A
LOCAL MISS THE POLITY. THAT'S A
STATE RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT AS THE RITALIN CORNELIA
WE'VE TAKEN ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND I SAY WE I
MEAN MY DEPARTMENT. AT MY
DEPARTMENTS EXPENSE.
TO BUILD AN EXPANDED DESPAIR
CENTER AND. DOING THIS INCIDENT
STAFF ADDITIONAL DISPATCHERS AND
ARE DYING.
I NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BECAUSE I
FEEL THAT. AS WE HAVE FURTHER
DIALOGUE THERE PRINCIPALLY BEING
THE STATE'S DIME OF THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT IT'S DIFFERENT IN
ARTICULATED WITH THOMAS FIRE DID
OCCUR. IN THE SYSTEM IS
ANTIQUATED AND SLOW AS MY
COUNTERPART I'M JUST INDICATED.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE DO
MAKE PHONE CALLS.
AND I WAS AWARE THAT THOMAS FIRE
pDEPLOY FOR THE RED FLAG A BIT
BECAUSE WHEN RED FLAG WHETHER
ALSO. BETWEEN MYSELF MY
COUNTERPART BERMAN SHOWROOM I
CAN'T PERSONALLY CITY. I MADE
THE DECISION TO SEND FOR STRIKE
TEAMS TO VENTURA COUNTY THAT
NIGHT.
AND THAT'S TWENTY ENGINES FOR MY
DEPARTMENT ALONG WITH CREWS AND
COPTERS. LA SEE AMELIE SENT ONE.
OUR HOPES WERE TO KEEP THE FIRE
FROM GETTING LARGE.
BUT THAT IN THE CURRENT BUT
CHILDREN'S AND DID USE THOSE
RESOURCES TO SAVE LIVES. AND SAY
PROPERTY.
THE BACKUP PLAN WAS REALLY CITY
TO BACK UP MY JURISDICTION UNTIL
THE NEXT DAY.
THE NEXT DAY AREN'T.
TWO ADDITIONAL FIRES ACCORDINGLY
COUNTY.
THE CREEK FIRE AND AND.
ALONG THE TWO TEN FREEWAY.
ALONG SILMAR SILMAR SUMAR. AND
IN THE RYE FIRE UP ANDSENATE
READER MORNING THE BORDER OF OF
LA COUNTY. AND VENTURA. I WILL
SAY THIS.
IS THERE IS ARTICULATED EARLIER
THIS IS THE PLACE TO ME BEING
THE CHAIR OF OUR SCOPE FIRES ARE
GOING TO OCCUR.
I MEAN WE LIVE IN THE STATE IN A
REGION WHERE FIRES HAVE BEEN
OCCURRING FOR.
USE A YEARS WE'RE GONNA CAR BUT
IT'S MORE DYNAMIC NOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE
OF OUR PRE POSITIONING. AND ALL
CLING STAFF IN RELATION TO THE
TO FARTHER CANNELLA COUNTY. SO
OF THE THE CREEK FIRE IN THE
RIGHT FIRE. WE KEPT THOSE PARTS
IN GETTING LARGER.
AS AN EXAMPLE.
.
BEFORE THE.
CREEK FIRE.
WE HAD A SIMILAR FIRED THAT
OCCURRED. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
OF THAT SAME FOOTPRINT AS A
RACER AMOUNT OF ACRES HAVE
BURNED.
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE
BURNED APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED HOMES.
FISHER TWENTY SEVENTEEN SAYING
FOOTPRINT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE RESOURCES
PRE DEPLOY PRE POSITION WE ONLY
BURN SIXTY HOMES.
I'M ON THE ON THE RIGHT FIRE
THOSE ALONG THE. LA COUNTY
VENTURA COUNTY BORDER.
UNFORTUNATELY PEPFAR ACCORDING
TO THOUSAND THREE.
AND THE BURN FROM MY
JURISDICTION INTO VENTURA
COUNTY.
IT WAS OVER A HUNDRED A HUNDRED
A THOUSAND ACRES.
AND OVER SIXTY HOMES WERE LOST
THEN.
BUT THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF PRE
POSITIONING FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
AND REFUSES WELFARE. WE KEPT
THAT FIRE UP TO BELOW TEN
THOUSAND ACRES ONLY BRING
FIFTEEN ACRES AND.
VENTURA COUNTY. LAST TIME IT
OCCURRED WE BURN ABOUT EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRES THIS TO GIVE YOU
A PERSPECTIVE OF THE VISIT
RELEASE TO US OF THE. LOCAL
MERCIFULLY AS FAR AS AUGMENTING
STAFF FROM PRE POSITIONING.
.
MY PERSPECTIVE IS THIS.
IS THAT IN ADDITION TO LISTEN TO
MY PEERS TALK ABOUT IMPROVING
TECHNOLOGY.
WE NEED TO REALLY FOCUS ON. THE
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES BECAUSE
THESE BARS DO OCCUR LOCALLY. I'M
NOT GONNA SAY THEY'RE CERTAIN
INCIDENT THESE FIRES ARE GONNA
GROW LARGE.
BUT.
AS AN EXAMPLE AND LA COUNTY.
FROM DECEMBER I'M FOURTH.
THE DECEMBER TWENTIETH I'M WE
WOULD EVEN RED FLAGS BAR. WATCH.
FIRE OR.
.
EXTREME FAR WHETHER.
WE HAVE FIFTEEN FIRES DURING
THAT TIMEFRAME.
WE KEPT THOSE FIFTEEN FIRES LEFT
IN TEN ACRES.
AND FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THAT'S
BECAUSE WE HAD PRE POSITION
UNITS AND WHEN PRONE AREAS. OR
HIGH FIRE DANGER AREAS THAT WHEN
WE HAD THOSE RESPONSES THAT WE
HAD IT ALTERNATE RESPONSE THE
KEEPERS FAR FROM ANY LARGE.
EXCUSE ME MY VOICE IS A LITTLE
BIT LEVEL CODE.
BUT IN CONCLUSION.
INITIATIVE TECH THE TECHNOLOGY.
THE PRE POSITIONING.
.
I CANNOT LEAVE YOU WITHOUT
TALKING ABOUT. HAVING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE SYSTEM.
I HAVE ONE OF THE LARGER
MUNICIPAL APARTMENTS IN THE. ON
THE STATE'S SECOND ACCOUNT FIRE.
RELATION TO PERSONNEL TO FAR
STATIONS.
I'M AFTER DAY THREE OF THE FAR
SEASON SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE SUPPORTING FOR FIRES THE
THOMAS FIRE. THE CREEK FIRE.
THE RIGHT FIRE AND THEN DALY
CITY AT ANOTHER ISN'T THIS
GLOBAL FIRE WHERE WE SUPPORT
RESOURCES THERE.
BUT AFTER DEPLOYING ALL OF OUR
RESOURCES WE HAVE A DEBT OF
SIXTY ADDITIONAL RESERVE AND IS
IN OUR DEPARTMENT.
OTHER HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
STATIONS I HAVE ABOUT TWO THIRDS
OF THOSE WERE ALLOCATED TO
WILDLAND FIRES.
AFTER DAY THREE WE HAD ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED FIREFIGHTERS. THAT
SHOW UP TO WORK.
BUT NO APPARATUSES STAFF.
BECAUSE ALL THE RESOURCES IN OUR
JURISDICTION IN OUR REGION.
WERE.
ALLOCATED INCIDENTS AND WE HAD
FIVE HUNDRED FIREFIGHTERS THAT
HAD NO RESOURCES
THE STAFF SO.
.
S. BET THAT NEEDS TO BE ON THE
TABLE I'M I'M I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE FACT THAT WE'RE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION. HOPEFULLY THE THE
THE.
THE RESULTS OF THIS CONVERSATION
AND THE RECOMMENDATION OF THIS
CONVERSATION. ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED.
I SAY THAT TO SAY THIS IS THERE
HAS THE CHAIR FAR SCOPE WE HAD A
SIMILAR CONVERSATION. WE HAD A
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION REPORT
THAT WAS DONE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. IN UNISON TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND NOT ALL THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE IMPLEMENTED
SOME HOPEFUL WITH A NEW.
LEADERSHIP.
AND NEW CHIEFS IN THE ROOM THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING. THAT AS A BODY.
WE'RE GONNA COME WITH SOLUTIONS.
HAPPEN WITH THOSE SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE
BEST PROP POSSIBLE.
BARBARA TEXAS THEY DO THINK
TUESDAY TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MANY MEMBERS.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU FUTURE
AND THE I JUST WANNA MAKE AN
OBSERVATION IF I COULD VERY
BRIEFLY BECAUSE I KNOW WE HAVE
TO MOVE ON BUT I IT'S BEEN IT'S
IS SO IMPRESSIVE TODAY WHAT I'VE
LEARNED.
AND AND WHAT I'VE LEARNED IS
THAT.
YOU KNOW THE THE IDEA OF ONE
TEAM ONE ONE FIGHT.
AND THE DEFIANT THIS FIRE
SCIENCE THAT WE HAVE OBSERVED.
IN THE LEADERSHIP OF ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS AROUND THE STATE IT
WHETHER IT'S IN SANTA ROSA WHERE
YOU PROBABLY YOU COULD BE
DEALING WITH A SMALL FIRE ON A
REGULAR BASIS A HOME FIRE. OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT THEY
WERE. THAT.
DISASTER.
YOU HAVE THE ABILITY AND THE
KNOWLEDGE IN THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE SKILL SET.
FIGHT AND TAKE ON THAT THAT
FIGHT IN A FIRE THAT'S WHAT'S SO
IMPRESSIVE ABOUT YOU YOU DON'T
YOU DON'T LIVE.
YOU DON'T DEAL WITH IT BUT YOU
LIVE FOR THE FACT THAT YOU CAN
TAKE CARE OF IT WHEN IT HAPPENS
AND FATS WITH BEEN SO IMPRESSIVE
TODAY AND WHAT I'VE LEARNED
THROUGH THE SYSTEM WITHIN. THE
DIRECTOR OF UP OH YES IN AND
MARK ARE GOING TO DO CHIU YIN
CAN COME WITH THE CHIEF.
JUST HOW IT ALL CAME TOGETHER.
MAYBE NOT WITH OF THE THE BEST
RESOURCES THAT YOU DO IT BUT
JUST HOW IT WAS DESIGNED TO WORK
AND IT DIDN'T WORK SO WELL SO
THANK YOU FOR THE LEADERSHIP AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE MEN AND
WOMEN. IN YOUR DEPARTMENTS WHO
MADE IT HAPPEN BECAUSE YOU
REALLY DID SO THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU CHAIR AYE AYE
YES AND I'M I REALLY APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS CENTER HILL I
THINK THAT'S.
BEYOND.
ABSOLUTELY HUNDRED PERCENT TRUE
THE THREE TAKEAWAYS AND I'D TAKE
AWAY FROM HERE AND WAS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AND LET ME TELL YOU
IS SO VALUABLE. FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR FIRST HAND.
I YOUR ALL YOUR THOUGHTS ON.
.
ARE MUTUAL AID WITH IT PRE
POSITIONING. IS VITAL NUMBER
TWO.
MUTUAL AID EYES NO LONGER IN
HOURS AND DAYS IT'S MINUTES AND
HOURS.
IN NUMBER THREE AYE WE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
DISPATCHERS
SO I'M REALLY.
THAT VOTE FOR ME THOSE ARE
THREE GREAT TAKE AWAY THAT GOT
MORE BUT. THOSE ARE YOU KNOW
VERY VERY POWERFUL I THINK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND FOR SHOWING UP TODAY
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'VE GOT OUR FINAL GROUP
WHICH IS IMPROVING MUTUAL AID
RESPONSE.
THEY NORMALLY DON'T ALLOW FIVE
SPEAKERS AT A TO MY HEARINGS
BUT.
IN THE SENSE OF FAIR PLAY WE
WERE GONNA LEAVE ANYBODY OUT IN
SO. WE'VE GOT ALL.
WE GOT MARQUARDT WE FOR THE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WE GOT JEFF MASTON
PRESENT ELECT THE FIRE. CAL FIRE
JESUS SO EXCUSE ME CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION ERIC
NICOLE PRESIDENT THE LEAGUE. OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES FIRE CHIEF
DEPARTMENT.
MIKE MCLAUGHLIN.
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE TASK
FORCE IN THE. CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND STEVEN
HOLL PRESIDENT FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE I RESPECT
WHAT YOU. BRING TO THE TABLE.
I'M GONNA ASK YOU THOUGH WE WE.
WE GOT TO GET THROUGH THIS THING
IN ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES SO.
PLEASE HELP ME OUT THERE THANKS
SO MUCH.
SIR THANK YOU FOR THE THE INVITE
FOR US.
TODAY.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
AYE WELL I WAS HOPING THE
SENATOR.
JACKSON WAS HERE BECAUSE I
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT ARE
MY PREDECESSOR LEFT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEF
SO TRACY HANSEN IS IN THE ROOM.
AND DOWN SHE SHE. CERTAINLY OUT
DOES ME AS A PRESIDENT I CAL
CHIEFS AND.
.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE SHE KNEW
THAT.
WE.
TRACY WAS A LEADER OF THIS
ORGANIZATION.
AND SHE'S HERE.
TODAY'S STAYING INTERESTED.
BUT I THINK WHEN THAT WOULD
SENATOR WHEN THE SENATOR GETS
BACK WE WILL MAKE NOTED THAT.
THANK YOU. FOR SURE NOTHING
THANK YOU SIR ONLY BECAUSE SHE
BROUGHT IT UP EARLIER OUT I'M
GOING TO LEON.
I'M GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE DON'T TAKE MORE OF YOUR TIME
WITH THEM I MEMBERS THAT THAT
THAT CAME
FOR S. ARE MET.
ASSOCIATION I I WANT YOU TO KNOW
TODAY I REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS.
THE COALITION THAT HAS COME
TOGETHER DISASTER.
READING AS FOR SAFER
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HEARD LOUD
AND CLEAR WE NEEDED TO SPEAK
WITH ONE VOICE AND I CAN TELL
YOU TODAY AS WE SIT HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU AND AS THE PREVIOUS
PANELS.
I'M SPECIFICALLY THE PREVIOUS
PANEL BEFORE ME SET BEFORE YOU
WE ARE UNITED IT IS ONE VOICE
THERE IS NOT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FIRE AGENCY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ISN'T
REPRESENTED HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
WE.
FROM THE FIRE DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS OF STEVE HALL.
WE HAVE THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
CAL OF CALIFORNIA LEGAL CITY'S
FIRE CHIEFS ERICH NICKEL
REPRESENTED HERE WE HAVE MY.
SUCCESSOR HERE VICE PRESIDENT
OF.
OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AN ALLEGED DIRECTOR
IS WELL WE HAVE THE METROPOLITAN
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THAT IS
ALSO PART OF THE COALITION WE
HAVE THE CULT
STATE. FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION
CASF A OR A.
HOPING TO BRING MORE.
GROUPS ON BOARD EVEN AS WE
SPEAK.
YOU.
ENCAPSULATED AT THEM VERY WELL
OF SENATOR WHEN YOU SAID PRE
POSITIONING. PRE POSITIONING FOR
US IS THE KEY AND WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PRE POSITIONING WE BELIEVE
PRE POSITIONING DISPATCHERS AND
THAT COMMAND CONTROL CENTER IS
VERY IMPORTANT BUT WE CUT WE
CONSIDER THAT PART OF PRE
POSITIONING.
WE.
TALKING ABOUT THAT CLUNKY NASA
SENSUALLY OF THE EXISTING MASTER
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM WORLD RENOWNED
TO BE SURE BUT CLUNKY AND THAT'S
PROBABLY THEBEST WAY TO PUT IT.
WITH THE EXISTING TECHNOLOGY AND
PROCESSES THAT.
ARE ARE TAKING PLACE IN AN
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND YOU
HEARD ABOUT THAT FROM THE
CALLAWAY AS DIRECTOR.
SHE AND MR GALLUCCI AND. I
WANNA GET INTO THE DETAILS SOME
OF THE MONEY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE'VE ASKED FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND PEOPLE HAVE
ASKED WILL YOU AND HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR SEEMS VERY ROUND
TO ME. HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THAT WILL LET ME TALK TO YOU
ABOUT WHAT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR US DOES?
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
DOESN'T COME CLOSE TO COVERING
ALL OF THE RED FLAG AND FLASH
FLOOD WARNING EVENTS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
WE KNOW THAT THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WHEN WE ASK FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE KNOW
THAT AT LEAST THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS WILL COME OUT. TO PRE
POSITION DISPATCHERS TO IMPROVE
COMMAND AND CONTROL AND TO TIE
WHAT DOWN ACHIEVE PIMLOTT
DISCUSSED ON THE GPS SYSTEMS
INTO THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM.
AS THE STATE IS DOING IT NOW
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT UNITS ARE
ALREADY EQUIPPED WITH GPS AND
pFAQ PART IS ONE OF THEM IT'S A
PROPRIETARY SYSTEM.
IN WHICH THESE RESOURCES ARE PUT
INTO ONE SYSTEM AND SO THE
CONTRACT THEM. REGIONALLY OR
STATEWIDE AS OPPOSED TO JUST ON
A LOCAL LEVEL WE KNOW THAT
BETWEEN THOSE SYSTEMS AND THE UP
STAFFING OR PRE POSITIONING OF
DISPATCH.
AND COMMAND THE CONTROL THAT
WOULD LIKELY BE AT LEAST
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT LEADS US EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
POSITIONING AND WHAT DOES THAT
DO.
FIVE.
ENGINE COMPANIES A STRIKE TEAM
WITH A LEADER IS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY IT'S ABOUT FORTY
SEVEN ON AVERAGE ABOUT FORTY
SEVEN NINE.
PER PER DAY. IF YOU TAKE THE
PRE POSITIONING THAT HAPPENED
JUST IN REGION ONE AND YOU HEARD
FROM REGION ONE WITH CHIEF OSBY
IF YOU TAKE THAT PRE POSITIONING
JUST IN REGION ONE. FOR ONE DAY.
IF WE WERE TO DO JUST THAT PRE
POSITIONING FOR ONE DAY IN
ANTICIPATION OF THAT EVENT IN
EACH OF THE SIX REGIONAL CENTERS
YOU WOULD LITERALLY HAVE TWENTY.
DAYS.
OF STAFFING.
THAT LITERALLY WOULDN'T COVER.
BUT PORTION EVEN A FRACTION OF
THE AMOUNT OF RED FLAG WARNINGS
IN A CLIMATE DRIVEN. A
PREDICTIONS.
EVENT PREDICTIONS THAT WE HAVE
BOTH FLASH OF FLOOD AND
A RED FLAG WARNING SO WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS A LOT.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IS A NEARLY ENOUGH TO
COVER THE EXPENSE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL INCUR.
SOMEBODY ASKED WELL WHAT IS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PAY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TODAY MY BUDGET ARE
NOT A CONTRACT COUNTY SO.
MOST OF MY UP STAFFING OR PRE
POSITIONING AND MUCH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SITE IS DETERMINED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR IN THE
BUDGET CYCLE. AND THEY'LL PUT A
FEW DAYS ASIDE FOR PRE
POSITIONING OR FOR UP STAFFING
WE CALL IT ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL. BUT THAT COMES
OUT OF OUR POCKET
AND SO WE ARE FACED ROUTINELY
WHERE. CHIEF THAT'S A RED FLAG
EVENT COMING UP OR CHIEF THERE'S
A FLASH FLOOD EVENT COMING UP
WHAT ARE YOU WHAT DO YOU HAVE
THE MONEY TO UP STAFF FOR AND
I'M WE'VE LITERALLY.
TAKE TURNS FIGURING OUT EXACTLY
USING PREDICTIVE MEASURE SLICK
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT WE
SHOULD ON STAFF UP FOR ANY GIVEN
EVENT.
WE KNOW WE ASK FOR A LOT.
WE'RE HERE TO TELL YOU WHAT WE
WILL USE WHAT WE GET IN THE
EXISTING SYSTEM OR NOT LOOKING
TO CREATE AN ADDITIONAL MUTUAL
AID SYSTEM WERE LOOKING AT USING
THE PREDICTIVE TOOLS IMPROVE
PREDICTIVE TOOLS THAT ARE AT
OUR.
FINGERTIPS WE ALSO LOOK AT USING
THE EXISTING MASS MUTUALLY
ORDERING SYSTEM REGION.
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO STAFF UP
THESE RESOURCES.
AND THEN.
FOR YOU ALSO TO KNOW THAT.
THE MONEY THAT YOU HAVE USE
WHAT ALSO PRE POSITION A
DISPATCHER SAYS WELL. WE'VE WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US THAT WE
ARE SPEAKING WITH ONE VOICE WE
EXPECT THAT VOICE TO CONTINUE
THROUGH THIS BUDGET A SEASON AS
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SPECIFICALLY TO PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES IN ANTICIPATION OF
THESE CLIMATE DRIVEN EVENTS.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
A GOOD MORNING SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE I WANT TO
GIVE A LITTLE SPECIFICS ABOUT
SOME OF THE MUTUALLY COMPONENTS
WE HAVE IT COVERED.
I THINK OF MY COLLEGE OF CHOSEN
ME TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU
BECAUSE.
THEY THOUGHT I WAS RAN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY WILL YA CAME UP
WITH A SYSTEM. BUT WE CERTAINLY
HAVE A.
GREAT SYSTEM BUT IT'S A
REACTIVE SYSTEM AND WE REALLY
NEED TO MAKE A PROACTIVE.
I THINK THAT'S THE THREAD THAT
WEAVES THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PRESENTATION TODAY REACTIVE TO
PROACTIVE.
WE ARE MADE UP WITH LOCAL STATE
FEDERAL TRIBAL AND MILITARY
AGENCIES HAS SORT OF MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM IS.
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE'S ABOUT ONE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED FIRE
DEPARTMENTS
ABOUT FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS.
WELL WE HAVE ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
FIRE APPARATUS.
THE STATE CALIFORNIA ZERO YES
HAS A HUNDRED SIXTY SIX OH YES
ENGINES.
RIGHT NOW WE CAN MOBILIZE ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED FIRE APPARATUS
WITHIN TWELVE HOURS.
AND WE CAN MOBILIZE ANOTHER FIVE
HUNDRED FIRE APPARATUS WITHIN
THAT TWENTY FOUR HOUR PERIOD.
BUT IS PREVIOUS SPEAKERS HAVE
SHARED WITH YOU. IT'S NOT OURS
IT'S MINUTES AND THAT'S WHAT WE
REALLY REALLY NEED TO CONSIDER.
SO AGAIN.
THOSE WERE SOME OF THE FACTUAL
NUMBERS A WE HAVE WITHIN OUR
STATE THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS
WHY WE'RE WE ARE SMALL AS WE
ARE.
AND THE STATUS IS LARGE IT IS
AS BUT.
THAT PRE POSITIONING WILL BE
KEY FOR US THANK YOU.
YOU.
WE DUGGAR DID DO EAT I'M I'D
MORE HAPPY I I DO I PUSHED YOU
AT THE BEGINNING BUT.
.
YOU'RE MORE THAN WELCOME TO
SPEAK YOU'VE COME THIS WAY ALL
THIS HUESO APPRECIATED. OFFERING
TO TEAR DOWN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME STEVEN HOLL ON
THE PRESIDENT OF A FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA.
BUT I REPRESENT.
PROMPTLY HUNDRED FOURTY FIRE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
FROM THE SMALL VOLUNTEER FIRE
COMPANIES TO THE LARGE ARE
COUNTY AND DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
HUNDREDS OF EMPLOYEES WITH THEM.
ARE I'M NOT GOING TO REITERATE
ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN SAID I
THINK.
CHAIRMAN YOU HIT ON THE HEAD
WITH YOUR THREE POINT CENTER.
AND IT BUT AS CHIEF MUST INVEST
MENTIONED IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
WE WERE ABLE TO PUT ELEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENGINES ON THE ROAD. IF TODAY WE
CAN ONLY DO HALF OF THAT TOO
AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED ENGINES.
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS IT
IS I BELIEVE OBVIOUS.
IT REQUIRES THE FUNDING AT TO
GET THESE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO THE PRE
POSITIONING THAT WERE WERE SO
MUCH IN DIRE STRAITS FOR.
THAT THANK YOU BAXTER.
WELL GOOD MORNING CHAIR OF MY
NAME IS ERIC NICKEL.
I AM THE FIRE CHIEF FOR THE
CITY OF PALO ALTO AND STANFORD
UNIVERSITY SERVANTS SENATOR
HILLS DISTRICT AND I COME HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO CITIES OF THE
LEAGUE ASSOCIATE THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS VERY SHORT
ON THE CLIMATE CHANGE GUY I
THINK IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE
STATE AND CITIES HAVE REALLY
TAKEN THE LEAD ON ON CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I KNOW THAT THE FOCUS OF HIS
IS REALLY ON THE MUTUAL AID AND
I WILL. TELL YOU TWO STORIES YOU
KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT SEVERAL
HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
EXPERIENCE.
WITH OUR OUR GROUPS HERE TODAY
AND LIKE MANY OF US WE STARTED
AS.
A SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS I
STARTED TO OUR FOR THE UNITED
STATES FOR SERVICE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IT WAS UNUSUAL BACK
THEN.
IF WE BURN A THOUSAND ACRES IN
ONE DAY.
AND YOUR EYES IS A WIDE OPEN
TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD TO BE LIKE
OH MY GOSH THOUSAND ACRES.
WELL FIRE BURNED THROUGH THAT
AREA AND IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
SAN FAR NORTHERN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. BURN TWENTY THOUSAND
ACRES LITERALLY IN AN AFTERNOON.
AND FOR THOSE OF US THAT HAVE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR ALL THESE
YEARS TO SEE THIS CHANGE.
JUST IN HUMAN LIFESPAN NOT
CLIMATE LIFESPAN BUT HUMAN
LIFESPAN. IT IS VERY SCARY ONE
OF THE EXCITING THINGS ABOUT
BEING THE FIRE CHIEF IN THE
BIRTHPLACE OF SILICON VALLEY IS
YOU DO GET TO PEER OVER. THE
HORIZON AND SEE WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE.
AND THE FUTURE WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE IS SPEEDING UP VERY
RAPID.
CHANGES.
WHAT WE'RE HERE TODAY ASKING IS?
SUPPORT NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT
ONGOING SUPPORT TO SPEED UP OUR
RESPONSE AND ARE PROACTIVE
RESPONSE TO THOSE CHANGES.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
TO SHARE ALL OUR OUR STORIES
ARE CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THURMOND IS MIKE
MCLAUGHLIN THE FIRE CHIEF OF THE
CASINOS FIRE DEPARTMENT AND ELK
GROVE I'M HERE TODAY BEFORE U.
S. IT LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION A VERY THANKFUL FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY VERY THINK OF.
WE'VE HAD THIS MORNING NAM
OBVIOUSLY WERE BEFORE YOU
BECAUSE THERE'S A VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT ADDRESS AND A.
SENATOR DODD IN EXCEPTIONAL JOB
OF RECAPPING THE THREE KEY THE
KEY POINTS OF THOSE ARE REALLY
THE THREE KEY POINTS WE CAME.
HOME. WITH THAT MYSELF THIS
MORNING TO BE ABLE TO BRING TO
YOU AND YOU DID A GREAT JOB OF A
BRING THAT FORTH I THINK I'M AN
IMPORTANT PIECE. UNTO EXISTED
JUST TO RECAP ON WHICH HE FIGHT
WEEK MATCHES WERE NOT LOOKING TO
CREATE A NEW SYSTEM WENT OUT
LOOKING TO DO ANYTHING NEW WERE
LOOKING TO USE THE EXISTING
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. AB DEBILITY
DUE TO CREATE ORDERS AND
REQUESTS FOR INDIVIDUAL
RESOURCES WE JUST NEED THE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT IT THIS
FUNDING CURRENTLY EXISTS ON. ON
THAT CAL FIRE SIDE THE HOUSE FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO PRE POSITION
TO SOME DEGREE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY FROM THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT WE CAN
MOBILIZE THE MEN AND WOMEN. ON
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO BE ABLE
TO HELP US GET OUT IN FRONT IN
ADVANCE THIS SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO CREATE SOMETHING NEW
WERE LOOKING TO BASICALLY BUILD
UPON. THE GREAT SYSTEM THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
LET ME SEE CHIEF ART WE DO WANNA
I INTRODUCED HER CALLING WE HAD
WHILE YOU WERE OUT OF THE ROOM
WE HAD IT INTRODUCTION THAT.
SENATOR JACKSON THE YOU MISSED
AND WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO DO IT TWICE SO THAT
YOU CAN.
MADAM CHAIR WHEN IT ONE OF THE
WOMEN IN THE FIRE SERVICE.
SO IT IS THAT MALES AND.
AND WHO LED US AS MY PREDECESSOR
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEF THIS CHIEF
TRACY HANSEN THAT SHE'S ACTUALLY
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE SHE STAYS
ENGAGE WITH US AND AS A AS A
GREAT MEMBER OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU ARE
AWARE THAT. THANK YOU I KNOW THE
WORLD A NUMBER OF OF FEMALE
MEMBERS WHO WERE PARTICIPATING
IN VERY SUPPORTIVE OUR CAPTAIN
PONCE OF OUR C. H. P. IN AND THE
THOMAS FAR INTO BUT WAS
UNBELIEVABLE. JUST LOOKING OUT
HERE I WAS JUST WONDERING WHERE
THEY WORK BUT I'M GLAD WE HAVE
AT LEAST ONE HERE AND. AND
TRUTHFULLY I DO THINK TO IT THIS
WE SHOULD TAKE THIS AS AN OPTION
TO BRING MORE. OF OUR WOMEN INTO
TO SERVICE I THINK THEY THAT
THEY GENERALLY SPEAKING DO AN
EXTRAORDINARY JOB AND ARE. OF
GREAT ASSISTANCE YOU KNOW THIS
AND I JUST IF I COULD.
ONE OF THINGS THAT WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT I WAS JUST TALKING
THE BY LOCAL DA AND A FEW OTHER
FOLKS HAVE BEEN ENGAGED. IN THIS
WHOLE ISSUE WE DIDN'T HAVE OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS HERE
NECESSARILY BUT OUR SHERIFFS
AND.
POLICE ARE VERY INTEGRAL
PARTICULARLY TO THE EVACUATION
PROCESS WHICH IS SAKE BUT.
YOU KNOW SO MUCH OF THIS IS NOT
JUST FIGHTING A FIRE IT'S
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU GO THROUGH.
ARE IT TALKING OF THE.
FIRM DE A HER SON AS FAR
FIGHTER AND DURING THE FIRST OF
THE MONTH SITES HELPED. SHAPE
ABOUT A HUNDRED PEOPLE INCLUDING
USE ONE OF THE.
THE FOLKS WHO WHO SAY THAT TWO
YEAR OLD UP FROM THE MUD TO THE
DEBRIS. AND BUT YOU KNOW THE
IMPACT IT HAS ON YOU AND I THINK
WE ALSO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE OUR
HUMANITY.
AND THE WORK THAT YOU DO.
AS YOU'RE OUT THERE TRYING TO
SAVE LIVES BUT TRYING TO REDUCE
THE DAMAGE XIN.
DEALING WITH THE TRAUMA
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE FIRES
RICHEST OUR OUR HUMANITY WE
CAN'T IGNORE IT AND SO. I THINK
TO WHEN WE HAVE. A A I KNOW IT'S
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TOUGH GUYS IN
THOSE UNIFORMS BUT. I TEND TO MY
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN WE HAVE.
ARE NOT WOMEN. UP THERE WITH A
SAY THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
COMFORTABLE EXPRESSING THAT
HUMANITY IN I THINK IT BENEFITS
ALL OF US TO RECOGNIZE THE THE
DIFFICULTIES EMOTIONAL
DIFFICULTIES THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
CHALLENGES NOT TRUST AS YOU
FIGHT THESE FIRES. BUT IN THE
AFTERMATH.
YOU KNOW THE PTSD THAT THAT
OCCURS I THINK THESE ARE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT AS
WELL IT'S NOT TODAY'S HEARING
BUT. RECOGNIZING THAT YOU DO
EXTRAORDINARY WORK THAT THE AND
YOU'RE IN THE ADRENALINE THE
SEARCHES PUMPING UNTIL YOU. ARE
EXHAUSTED AND AND THEN YOU
CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD I MEAN
WE OWE YOU A GREAT DEBT OF
GRATITUDE BUT. BASS HAVE TO RIP
REALIZED THE HUMANITY OF
EVERYONE AND WHEN YOU SAY WE
NEED MORE. OF PEOPLE THERE.
WE ALSO NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BRING IN YOU KNOW THAT RESEARCH
FOR HIM AFTER YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH THESE EXPERIENCES SO. I
MENTION THAT BOTH BECAUSE I DO
THINK IT IS A BENEFIT TO ALL OF
US AND ALSO RECOGNIZING THE
EXTRAORDINARY.
.
WORK YOU DO IN THE DIFFICULTY OF
THE WORKING DAY SELF I. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
pIF WE GOT A QUESTION I'M SORRY
CENTER HILL. AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF.
YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED A LOT
TODAY ABOUT THE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND CLIMATE EVENTS WHICH HAVE
CERTAINLY BEEN.
COMING IT AT A GREATER PACE
CERTAINLY AND AND THAT ARE THE
KIND OF THE FUTURE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH ONE OF THE ISSUES
AND AND A CHIEF NICKEL WHERE WE
LIVE FITS.
YOU KNOW THAT THE IDEA OF A
WILDFIRE IT'S POSSIBLE CERTAINLY
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT COFFEE
PARK WOULD HAVE BEEN ATTACKED
HIS IT WAS. AND WE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL IN THE WATERSHED AND
AND AND IN OUR AREA AREA.
BUT TO ONE OF THE ISSUES IN
LOOKING AT THE THE IDEA OF A PRE
POSITIONING AND SOME OF THE WORK
THAT THE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
WOULD BE.
LOOKING THAT CONTRIBUTING รณ ON
AN ONGOING BASIS BUT ONE OF THE
THREATS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS A
EARTHQUAKES.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT WE KNOW IS COMING.
A HOW. WOULD THIS.
FUNDING AND THAT SOME OF THESE
RESOURCE CHANGES ALLOCATIONS HOW
WOULD THAT WORK TOWARDS A.
BETTER BETTERING OUR PER
PREPAREDNESS FOR EARTHQUAKE CHO
RESPONSE.
IF IF I COULD YEAH I THINK
THAT'S SPECIFICALLY THE MONEY
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW IS TO
PRE POSITIONED RESOURCES IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE PREDICTED
EVENTS AND SO. WHEN WE THINK OF
THOSE WE THINK OF THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE THE NOAH THAT
COMES UP WITH THE AND HAS A VERY
ROBUST. A RED FLAG AND FOR A
FLASH FLOOD PREDICTION OF THE
PER PREPAREDNESS IN FACT THE
CHIEF CLERK EACH YEAR MISTER
GORE DO SHE FROM THAT COLOR WE
S. DIRECTOR'S POSITION.
MOBILIZED A VERY ROBUST NETWORK
OF.
RESCUE RESPONSE TEAMS
ESSENTIALLY REGIONAL BUT.
RESPONSE TEAMS
SPECIFICALLY IN THE MONTICELLO
FLOODS AND SO WE CONTINUED OF TO
TO BUILD ON.
THAT CAPABILITY BUT I THINK THE
MONEY WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND.
A AND PERHAPS THAT WE COULD OF
ADDRESS THAT AND THE OTHER
HEARING ABOUT HOW THESE REGIONAL
ATTACHED FORCES THAT.
MR GALLUCCI AND FELLOW WE HAVE
SAYS FOR A.
GATHERED TOGETHER HAS MADE SUCH
A HUGE DIFFERENCE SPECIFICALLY
BEEN IN THE MOST RECENT. EVENTS
AND THEN WE'LL PLAN.
THE EARTHQUAKE COMES WHICH IT
WILL AND WE AND WHERE WE WILL BE
PREPARED EVEN A BETTER PREPARED
TO RESPOND TO THE CITY'S TASK
FORCE. IT IN THAT IS GOOD TO
HEAR AND I KNOW THAT IT DIRECTOR
GOING TO CHEER AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM UNFORTUNATELY
THAT THIRTY SECOND OR FORTY FIVE
SECOND WARNING IS AGO A LOT NOT.
A LOT OF TIME FOR PRE
POSITIONING FOR THAT BUT THAT IT
WILL BE GOOD TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION IN THE FUTURE AS WE
LOOK AT IT. SENATOR PRIMARY AYE
I HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING ON
THE.
SO
NETWORK
UNDER THE.
SCHWARZENEGGER ADMINISTRATION
AND YES WE DO HAVE THAT EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM THAT'S IN PLACE
THE BEAUTY OF THAT ISN'T
NECESSARILY THE EARLY WARNING
IT'S KNOWING WHERE THE SEISMIC
CENTER IS OR THE CENTER OF THE
EVENT. AND WE IS A FIRE SERVICE
WILL BE ABLE TO REACT BASED ON
THAT WITH SOME OF THIS PRE
PLANNING AND AGAIN AND GOES BACK
TO HIS EARLIER COMMENTS ABOUT
SECONDS AND MINUTES AS COMPARED
HOURS.
ARE YOU KNOW WE ARE VERY CAPABLE
IN THE STATE NOT NLY WITH OUR
FEDERAL URBAN SEARCH RESCUE
TEAMS BUT ALSO OUR STATEWIDE
URBAN RESCUE TEAMS. OBSERVE THAT
QUITE UNIQUE.
IN OURS COUNTACH OUR STATE AS A
WHOLE SO AGAIN I I THINK IF WE
KNOW WHERE THE EPICENTER IS AND
WE WILL.
THEN WE WILL BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATELY SEND THE RIGHT
DISPATCHES QUICKLY AND THAT'S
WHERE THAT AVIELLE WILL COME IN
AND.
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATION SO I
I'VE I THINK IT DOES FIT INTO
THAT PLAN.
NETWORK ADMIN.
I DEAL WITH THAT FOR YEARS
ACTUALLY SO THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY.
WOULD WOULD YOU WOULD GENERALLY
PLEASE STAY PUT I'M GONNA GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW MAYBE IF
THERE ARE ANY UP PUBLIC COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS AYE YOU COULD
ADDRESS THOSE ANYBODY WISH
SEEING.
I TO SPEAK AS MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC.
SEEING NONE.
WELL LET ME JUST SAY.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS A GREAT
HEARING EVERY SINGLE SPEAKER
CONTRIBUTED.
TO OUR KNOLEDGE BASE TODAY AT
THE AGE I'M JUST FRANKLY AMAZED
AND APPRECIATIVE. OF EVERY ABOUT
EVERYONE OF YOU THE
CAME UP AND
IF I'D BE FORCED DAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY VERY MUCH THAT. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED